we're going to get started as soon as uh
representative walner
comes back into the room
all right it being 105. uh i'm going to
call into session this
work group on uh from division three uh
we have seven bills to go over today
uh and
some of these are pretty complex so it
could take quite a while we're gonna
take them in the order that they're
listed
so if you're here only because of sb 459
you have my apologies up front because
you're going to hear a lot of stuff that
have nothing to do with 459 for the next
many many hours
so um we're going to uh oh so where are
we now we are
at
a place i don't really like being at we
uh got these bills most of these bills
um last thursday
we've only had a chance to talk about
two of them so the other five are all
fresh to the committee
and so um in many of them over the
weekend um the vice chair and myself
have have coordinated with mr ripple or
representative from lba
to
draft an amendment or i have drafted in
a word document something i would just
call a discussion draft for us to look
at so we have today to talk we're not i
don't anticipate
uh voting out anything other than maybe
sb 275 because it's not on the calendar
for tomorrow
and um but other than that
we're going to prepare ourselves so that
we can have any amendments done so that
we can vote out amendments tomorrow
where appropriate so that'll be make us
ready for
the wednesday finance section
so if there are no questions on what
we're doing
let's go ahead and start a hearing on sb
is is there anyone in the audience that
came to talk to us about 275
so so uh representative irf
from your seat would you would you tell
us what you think 275 does and if you
have any issues with it
thank you mr chair um what it does
it's basically an or
a fund
opioid at the opioid abatement fund for
what from which people can apply for
grants to work on reducing opioid
abuse
and the one area of the bill that i
question it's not really questioned it
but i think she may be maybe extended
is uh section three
that relates
to the
it says it relates to the duties it's
actually changing around
who can apply for the grants
and on line 20 number 16 subsection 16
of
what is it uh
rsa 126-8 colon 86 i b plan b
uh says that public school programs can
apply for these grants which makes
perfect sense but it would seem that
that should be more inclusive
of
these charter schools and other kinds of
educational environments since i'm
assuming that everybody wants to have
kids be able to get these
grants to help the students as it says
in services for students with oud and
any
co-occurring sud
mh issues or who have been affected by
oud and any co-occurring sud slash mh
issues within their family
there are also a couple of little minor
um technical things like the word the
letters are they aren't in there but i'm
sure that's what's intended
um
and uh
yeah that's it
uh thank you for doing that and um
division three doesn't deal with
educational programs and so i'm
unfamiliar
with what the appropriate term of art is
or should be on line 16. if we intend
for
educational settings
greater than just the public schools to
be able to apply
i you know i don't know if the languages
it's described there
uh is adequate or sufficient
um
uh mr ripple do you do do you happen to
have any insight into whether the phrase
public school programs is sufficient to
include things like charter schools and
other educational settings
uh this is one that
ols i believe is working on now
for an amendment and that was one of the
issues they were going to address and i
think i asked them to include language
such as
uh something like all public and
non-public schools so that would cover
everything
all right so
so we can just
effectively recess
this bill
and while we wait for the amendment
um
so
uh is there
any comment from uh the representatives
on the committee
good idea
okay okay so
uh i'm gonna put sb 275 in recess
awaiting uh the amendment be to be
delivered
with that
we go to opening sb 407
this is a an act relative to expanding
medicaid to include certain postpartum
health care services and making an
appropriation therefore
[Music]
so representative irf do you want to do
something similar to what you just did
on um 275 to give us an introduction on
what 2
407 does
so i think we have mr lipman here for
you you would be
available to introduce this bill and
tell us what you think it does and what
the department position is right
so let's do that instead all right come
on up please and uh we'll of course need
your name for the record and everything
good afternoon for the record henry
lipman i'm state medicaid director
senate bill
fills in an important gap
for individuals women who deliver a baby
who
have
income level
just above 138
but below 196
they're only given 60 days
worth of coverage after they deliver the
baby
many of the conditions um and this is a
fairly small population for our actuary
in terms of the fiscal note that's in
front of you estimated
571 women
in state fiscal year
23 would apply to this um i i noted to
kevin uh i think the chair you had a
question
on that what what the number was and
we've seen as high as
761 going back to 19
but essentially what this does is you
know within 60 days some conditions
such as mental health sud but also
cardiovascular
conditions don't not necessarily fully
been able to be taken care of i guess
from an equity standpoint and someone
who's has a little bit more income
whether they be
employed or in the medicaid program who
can qualify for granted advantage would
continue to have coverage or if they
were poor enough if you will below the
138 they would continue to have coverage
so it kind of filling in the donut hole
here of of coverage for those women who
only allowed 60 days of coverage whereas
um you know others have a full year
may i ask you a question please was
you refer to it as a donut hole let's
use the phrase for a moment uh did this
donut hole uh exist prior to the
pandemic uh are we essentially
uh expanding the medicaid program
that's really what we're doing we're
expanding the medicaid program is that
correct
in part
but the what's what's new um the
american rescue plan of 21
provided for the first time
funding on a federal level to support
the the match to do so
and um
i think
vice chair has a copy of this map and
i've left others with uh
with
with kevin ripple
you know it's something that many states
both red and blue states are
are addressing based on the availability
of federal match that didn't exist
historically it's for a uh five-year
period
um i think the bill's been amended to my
understanding to
only run our if new hampshire were to
adopt it to that point um we understand
why that would be the case
and it's fairly small dollars again a
lot of the
the things that aren't taken care of
aren't big dollar
ticket items during that period but
they're important for
um the mom and raising the child um and
they're important for the mom's health
herself i think there's
um
in a mortality issue that sometimes
emerges in a subset of that smaller
population so if we're talking about 571
women in state fiscal year 23
a subset of them will
you know need services and um to
maintain their health
uh do you have a question representative
for the record can you go over the
the
three different
funding areas that you said there's a
doughnut hole so
okay um
so individuals who
make
who have income above 138 of the poverty
level
and up to
but less than 196 percent that's where
the
138 to 196.
that yes that would provide beyond they
would if you will equalize them to
others who have a little bit more money
or have a little bit less money
could do you have any understanding i'm
just curious 196 is a
peculiar number why how did that number
get picked 196 instead of 200 or some
other
um
i believe
i
i well i can confirm this with you but i
believe it's historically what the sort
of the federal limit was that new
hampshire adopted i think sometimes
states have the ability to go up a
little bit higher or but this usually a
threshold amount and i think that was
for that particular one new hampshire i
think adopted the the threshold amount
that was in the federal program and i'll
i'll confirm that uh it's not urgent all
right it just is just an odd number
makes me wonder
or do any other committee members have
any questions on this bill
representative long
thank you mr chairman
do you stated a number of 2019
761 cases is that the cases in the whole
or is that
so yeah so this is in
what we're projecting in the fiscal note
is 500 and um
500 i'm forgetting my number kevin is it
561 i believe is the number in in state
fiscal year 23.
um that's what our actuary in looking at
our enrollment is projecting would fall
into that
um
what i was just trying to um by talking
about 2019 what i'm trying to just bring
up that the number can fluctuate based
on the number of births in the year and
you know what income levels
people who deliver babies have so
um you know in terms of our fiscal note
we did
add some dollars to um
the base 561 to account for that that
could be fluctuation am i do i have that
number right
thank you
and just to be clear that number 561 or
700 from a couple years ago that's the
number of women in that doughnut hole
correct that would give birth or
expected to give birth not the ones that
were expected necessarily need these
extra services over the following year
correct it's i mean like anybody else
with health insurance is only a certain
portion of the individuals have to end
up using the services
um
all right
so any other questions by the committee
um
i i would like just to take a straw poll
on this
um
uh i
i i'm favorably disposed towards this
bill
i don't know where the rest of you are
at
so i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you to raise your hands if you
support 407 and then
after counting that we'll ask for a show
of hands if you oppose
407.
all those in favor raise your hand
those opposed so it looks to me it's
unanimous amongst the people here
um and then uh
representative walner
would you give me would you would it be
okay with you or would you have a
problem if i went ahead and we just uh
do
would you be able to support an official
vote on this today
that we could just get it out of our way
so tomorrow isn't as jammed
representative weiler
can you can you support a vote on this i
can't
represent walnut are you okay with the
vote
okay
okay so um i will allow uh
representative weiler to take our uh
vote when he's ready
correct
i'm sorry i'm forgetting my protocol i
need a motion
oh i'll move otp i'm really recommend
otp
okay thank you
is there any further discussion
i don't see any further discussion
promotion is not to pass
motion is not to pass on senate bill 407
if you're in favor of ought to pass you
will say yay if opposed you'll say nay
representative irf yes yay
representative weiler yay representative
bean
representative walner yes
representative
long yay
chairman edwards
uh six to zero thank you with that uh
we'll recommend uh otp to the full
finance committee uh is there anyone who
wants to write the committee report on
this you guys want to do you guys want
to do some work
okay
you got it all right thank you thank you
um all right so that closes 407 thank
you
so let's go on to
uh
uh 416.
this is relative to behavioral health
assessment and treatment for children in
out of home placements
is there somebody in the audience that
came wanting to talk about this
please please step forward
senator whitley it's good to have you
here
thank you mr chair it's so good to be
here um for the record my name is becky
whitley i'm the senator for district 15
um and um the prime sponsor of this bill
and with me i have rebecca ross who is
the head of the children's behavioral
health bureau
and we worked together on this bill with
a few other advocates
for children it was this issue was
actually brought to me by the office of
child advocate trying to think about how
do we better serve our kiddos who are in
residential treatment and out of state
they're you know there are there
even though we are building our system
of care there continues to be kiddos in
um out-of-state facilities
so we wanted to get something that was
workable for our school districts
so under special ed law school districts
have certain responsibilities to to do
these assessments so it was very
important to have the department of
health health and human services and the
department of education at the table so
we didn't so we made sure that um
you know each agency had the appropriate
responsibility in here so you'll see
that the house did amend it
in the policy committee um to reflect
some of the changes requested by the
department so happy to take any
questions but it's really just trying to
better assess children so we can get the
right treatment for them and you know
hopefully the less expensive treatment
do you have any testimony you want to
volunteer or
or should we just ask your questions
go for the questions
okay so um
i'm gonna
admit my ignorance out of the gate here
because this is a lot of education
policy and i'm not
steeped in education policy so
i
focusing on
page
paragraph three the new paragraph about
uh dealing with individual
individualized education programs
and
this looks like a
this is just yes or no and so i know
where i'm going
is this is this a new requirement
no
what we're trying to do is make clear
that um the school district does have
certain responsibilities when the child
does have an iep but we're not expanding
you know what the school is required to
do we're just clarifying it within the
context of this required behavioral
health assessment
and if you may remember if you you know
of course education is not you know be
before this committee often but there is
federal law and then there's state law
with special education
yeah okay so so
so you're convinced this is a
clarification of the existing
obligations and that if i went to my
principal and talked to her about this
she'd she'd say yeah
correct
okay are there any questions uh
representative irf
i will say i'm sorry i'm gonna take a
timeout and recognize that
representative walls has joined us um
and welcome
so we're
we we happen to be on the third bill of
the day 416.
we we have recess on 275.
go ahead mr chair i did want to say if
you look on page two
line eight
um about who can actually conduct these
fbas that language um
was actually requested by this by school
director to make sure it reflects who
actually conducts these assessments in
schools so we wanted to be reflective of
the practice in schools so it can be the
assessment can be
performed
uh by individuals who are qualified to
perform the assessment and there are
certain qualifications within medicaid
and that may include but it's not
limited to a board certified behavioral
analysis or psychologist and we added
psychologists because often
psychologists are the ones doing these
assessments in schools
representative earth did you have a
question
yes thank you mr chair
thank you taking the question
so can you tell me under what authority
an fba is required for every iep
special ed student
um
it's not required for every special ed
student
by putting in
this new section 4
into that rsa this reference there 186-c
colon 7
that is requiring it no it says if the
team has so the iep team is made up of
parent teacher
read the entire class yeah has
determined if if the team has determined
a positive inter intervention plan is
appropriate after review of an fba ma'am
did you hear we just you just read after
review of an fba how can you review an
fba that doesn't exist
so so what i know of special ed law is
that
the this this isn't creating but it's
the team that determines whether that
fba should be conducted
so where are you putting this into the
law
into our statutes
the statutes require those things to be
to happen for an iep which in this case
means you're now requiring an fba for
every iep
i i i'm sorry i don't read it that way i
don't read it as creating a new
requirement i don't know if you wanted
to comment on that
i'm not familiar with the department of
ed portion of it sufficiently to comment
on that i i will say that the department
of ed helped write this and so and that
is not how i understood it that's not
how they understood it
okay requiring an fba for every child
the commissioner seemed to have a
different point of view and
unfortunately i guess nobody was here
from the department of education to
address that so we'll need to look more
into it more deeply
is rebecca here today
for debt i i think i emailed her like
late sunday so it would be stunning if
you were here
okay uh mr ripple did did we do an
amendment and get our amendment ready
for this
uh yes you have the amendments that we
talked about
before the meeting would you like me to
hand out one or both of them
one one why don't you hold on uh hand
out the one that um we agreed we'd go
with
and by go with don't don't overread what
i'm saying it's the one that i said we
would discuss we haven't made any
determinations because
i am not steeped on educational policy
oh welcome
all right so um
so representative erf was just asking a
question and and we all acknowledged in
the room that we needed you so that's
why you're here so we're gonna we're
gonna back up and rewind and have
representative erv ask you the question
sure
well thank you mr chair
so i'm trying to understand it seems to
me
that when you put section 4
into rsa
186-c colon 7 which is basically the
requirements that have to be met
when putting together an iep
when you say
that if the team has determined a
positive education intervention plan is
appropriate after review of the fba
that that requires that an fba have been
performed
the only way that an fba would have been
performed if it was performed for every
student in the iep which is where this
law where this new clause is going into
the law
thank you for the question um there is
language in 186c that refers to a
functional behavior assessment
i got to stop you this clerk needs your
your full name and your title i'm sorry
nope that's okay i forgot my name is
rebecca ford i'm the state director of
special education
um so 180 can you spell for that sure f
r e
d e
t t
e thank you
so 18 in 186 c it does discuss
functional behavior assessments and a
team will determine to
to complete a functional behavior
assessment if it is needed
based on behaviors or a manifestation of
their disability so
we had put this in that if it is
determined that they need a positive
behavior plan they would put something
in but this language doesn't say to me
does not say that it has to be done
and we said we referred them back to the
cfr that relates to all discipline
procedures regarding a functional
behavior assessment
okay the cfr is the federal law right
yes it is i have that in front of me as
well if you could refer to anywhere in
186c
it talks about an fba that would be
helpful it's certainly in c colon 7 it
does not
i i would i apologize i would did not
know about this meeting until this
morning so i did not have anything with
me i was across the hall at division two
so i do not have it with me i can look
it up and get it to you but i know that
you're on a time frame so that'd be
great if you could just get to this um i
did send you an email with all this
information in it as well this morning
yes i got it this morning and then i
went to division two
i'm so sorry we we're in a scurry mode
we didn't have this bill until thursday
and this is first time we've had a
chance to talk about it so so we're all
just kind of in a little bit of a scurry
um
what would be the impact if we
just simply deleted
uh everything under
uh paragraph three new paragraph and
just deleted that whole section from
lines 12 to 23.
what bad stuff would happen what would
we break
if i were i haven't looked at this bill
in a while um if i remember correctly it
was requiring um that
pieces be put into the iep related to a
behavior plan and this would make it so
that it was not required that it was
only if the iep team determined that it
would be put into the behavior plan
into the iep excuse me so if the if they
looked at the functional behavior
assessment and said no this does not
impact them educationally it has nothing
to do with their disability they
wouldn't be required to put it in the
individual education program they would
be able to not put it in
i'm so sorry
in 10 words or less what would we break
if we deleted this paragraph
i'm happy to try to answer that one
the point of adding the clarity was to
make sure it was clear where the line
between the school district and the
department or dcyf or behavioral health
was drawn so that if it fell under
the school district
it would have certain things included
and if it did not it would be clear that
then it was
for dcyf or behavioral health to get the
functional behavioral assessment
consistent with what doe would be
getting
okay but so there's no change in the
responsibilities and relationships this
is just a clarification that's what i've
heard i there is a change because prior
to this bill there is no statutory
requirement for dhhs to do any of the
functional behavioral assessments um but
there's been a lot of confusion
um when the school district does it
what's included and what gets passed on
for kids who are also being served by
the department
so mr williams if you could just shake
your head yes or no
does the department support
416.
that's all right he just answered it uh
what i what i heard you just say is that
you have been in support of senator
whitley's drafting of the bill
but the department has not taken a
position in favor or in opposition
thank you um in principle we certainly
support the use of fbas when they're
appropriate however the department would
need the necessary resources enabled to
enable us to implement this
so i completely agree with what you just
said but one of you actually in the
senate testimony i remember who it was i
think it was well i won't say who i
think it was i'm not sure actually spoke
about the cost of these fbas and pointed
out that not they're not this is in the
senate testimony i'm referring to now in
the report that came out of the senate
that they're not inexpensive to perform
and you wouldn't want to be requiring
every
student with an iep to be having the fba
i assume that's correct okay correct so
if you could just help me don't do it
now but if you could
go through and explain to me um how
you know where the ruling where because
if i just read the very simple parts
that i read which is basically
186 sc colon 7
and then also 34 cfr 300 colon 530
um that whole thing f
none of that makes clear that in that an
fba
is otherwise required
is not otherwise required in other words
you're putting this into c7 which are
the requirements if i understand it are
the requirements for an iep the things
you have to do for an iep
so as soon as you put something in that
requires an fba you're in my world
you're adding that unless there's some
other place that says it's already what
she just was just mention that
only in a certain circumstance something
like that so if you just point me not
right now but just send me that
information i'd appreciate it it's
actually in the bill i just had a minute
to read it well um so if you look at
section 5 it says under
34 cfr 300.5
schools are required to conduct a
functional behavior assessment and
provide behavioral intervention services
any time a child is removed for more
than 10 days so it's referencing that
that's when we would do a functional
behavior assessment
um it is on line 16 of the bill on uh
the first page
number section five
exactly when they're removed yes
not when they're coded right so that so
that is what but
so then this clarifies more when we add
on section
on the back and number three when you
add that on it clarifies that if when
you look at that functional behavior
assessment you determine that their
their education needs that
positive intervention plan then you
would put those pieces into place
let me ask you this then so if you go to
look
and there isn't one
and you just skip over it
yep okay
so i'm going to read just a piece of the
lba uh write up on this and see if you
agree with it
um
the lba wrote
the department states that traditionally
the fba
has been used in education and specific
developmental diagnosis support the
department further states that if the
intent of the bill is to broaden the fba
beyond its traditional uses and into the
behavioral health arena there will be
likely a significant state cost the
department did not identify the extent
of any such additional costs
so
would you say the intent of this bill
is to broaden the fba
beyond its traditional uses
yes absolutely in the context of
behavioral health treatment not
exclusively in education so for a youth
who may be struggling with behavior at
home or in the community
but is not at school it would certainly
be an appropriate evaluation to help
assist
in developing the plan of care for that
youth so it's looking outside of the
school arena to home community and
residential where children and youth may
be struggling
so
so the
dilemma that i wrestle with and i'll
look to my committee members to help me
uh
uh get myself a little settled on this
point it seems to me like we're looking
at a significant
increase in state costs and we have no
idea how much that is
right isn't that
that's sort of a fair summary of where
we're at right
um with the amendment we have not
provided the updated fiscal note
worksheet we have one in the works and
we'll be providing that um i think we
can come up with a lot closer than then
no idea at this point now that we've
narrowed it down and identified the
scope through amendment
when might that cheat be prepared
because as i understand my deadlines i'm
i'm done with this tomorrow afternoon
and then i gotta turn it over to the
full finance committee
we can get it to kevin when i get back
to the office
that's pretty good
um
are there any questions on this i i i'm
about to show you an amendment we've
drafted but i want to have you all have
an opportunity to ask questions on this
point representative erf did you have
more
yes thank mr chair so if on line 15 we
opened that line up with something
effective if an fba exists for the
student
and
would that work for you yes that would
what did you just say
on line 15 of page
two
if an fpa exists fb
exist for the student and
then you continue in other words if
that's essentially what you just said
from section v back in
in
section one was was doing so this would
just clarify that in fact the fba has to
exist before you
go and look to see if it
recommends
and then i that makes sense then what
you say makes sense to me yes it does
you all can
stay there um
mr ripple handed out an amendment
uh 1738
is an amendment that basically just
strips out this entire paragraph
i what what that would
would what we thought what i thought
that would be doing is just um
avoiding the significant state costs
where we don't have an estimate
so we're going to be able to wait and
get more detail on that
and also
mr representative irf has suggested a
different amendment to make it
clear that if the fba fba exists it can
be used if it doesn't it doesn't need to
be generated
if if we did that amendment
would you would you all be in support
yes
so
if we're removing section three that
references the department of education
in that iep language
that would not have any impact on the
dhhs
estimates of costs that we'll be
providing because that would still be
the additional fbas through the
department of health and human services
um
i think i'll defer to rebecca on the
other part of your question
and the language that was proposed by
representative earth is fine with us
eliminating this we had put this in to
allow for districts to put language into
the iep if a functional behavior
assessment was done so if they
determined that they did not need one
based on their educational needs but
somebody from dhhs came with a
functional behavior assessment and said
we think you should look at some of this
information then that allowed the iep
team to look at it and say yes we could
add something to the iep because this
may start to impact them or we've it has
already started to and this is going to
help
us so
thank you so so mr ripple let me let me
ask you uh we've we've meandered a
little bit but we've stumbled upon a
different amendment
do you think what you know what we're
talking about and would you describe
what you think we're talking about back
to us
well so what i've heard so far is
representative earth's suggestion that
on page 2 line 15
the new line would effectively read if a
functional behavioral assessment
exists for the student and the iep team
has iep team has determined etc so is
that the only change that you're talking
about at this point
i i think so representative yeah
yes
okay and is it your understanding ms
ripple with that language that we would
probably avoid the state cost
well that's the part that i'm not sure
about because it sounds like the hhs
costs are located elsewhere in the bill
do you all want to respond to that yes
this is creating a completely new
service for most dcyf out of home
placement cases and that's where the
costs would lie in the first couple
sections of the bill
so i understood the amendment to not be
creating a new fba requirement
because we're going to say if it already
exists it can be referenced not that it
must be created to be referenced that
would be in the educational setting but
the bill is establishing an fba process
for the
um behavioral health or mental health
system that would be a new service and
would come at a cost to the department
okay so so this is where i think we're
at if if if we can have
i don't want to i don't want to stir ols
up if we don't uh need it but so let i
do want to take a straw vote
in the straw vote i want to take is
uh
yes ma'am please
i i apologize for interrupting i just i
um on the cost i um i appreciate you
turning that around so fast um i did
want to just bring the committee's
awareness to the effective date it shall
not take effect until january 1st 2024
and that was at the request of the
department so they could you know figure
out how to pay for this it may be that
it could be well i don't want to put
words in your mouth but there are
different ways that this could be paid
for through um
you know a negotiated contract with the
managed care companies there there are
different ways that it could be paid for
so
you know i just wanted to point out that
it won't take effect for
a couple years to give the department
the availability the the time to really
cost this out if that gives the
committee any solace
i would add that it's it's the cost as
well as the workforce that there would
have to be substantial efforts to
recruit the workforce to be able to meet
this obligation which is part of why we
asked for that additional time but we're
still going to have to identify a
revenue source in order to be able to
establish this benefit
and it and again it's not required for
every child going out of home we also
did another amendment um at the
department's request saying that it was
if necessary so it's not required for
every single child who's going out of
home so we thought that was a reasonable
agreement
and again you know if you're thinking
about the cost the whole backing up to
the whole point of this
is so we can save costs right we want to
figure out what the kids needs are so we
don't place them in a 30 000 a month
placement out of state in utah i'm not
saying that that happens but the whole
idea of it was there are a group of
children who are receiving out of home
care at a very high cost and if they can
be better served in new hampshire
somewhere else that's less expensive
with their needs met we want to do that
so that this is the balance here
so i i
i'm asking this respectfully
you're you're making some assumptions on
what we can do with an fba if it were
available
that we don't really have a
history with so so it is a little bit of
a hopeful guess
also isn't it well it's more than
hopeful i mean this was so our former
office of child advocate the head of she
was a nurse she has reviewed these cases
she knows the needs of these children
and it was her recommended
recommendation to do this so it's more
than a hope i would say
i'm wondering about language go ahead
and uh represent
page uh page 1 line 16
and and that paragraph talks about
more than 10 days
removed from school for more than 10
days
is it is should that be removed from
home
for more than 10 days um that is
tracking current federal law
that's talking about the special ed
context
it's just it's essentially just saying
what's in federal law
if if i'm not mistaken representative
weiler that relates to the section three
that i was talking about i don't believe
that relates to the section two does it
correct
so that was the uh the fba gets
triggered that impacts uh section three
and as long as we state in section three
that if the fba already exists then the
section three stuff will apply but the
part they're talking about now is the
section two part that's the part that
relates to dhhs correct and what they're
talking about correct thank you
representative thank you
i'm looking at um
at page one
line 21
where it's it says therefore this act
directs the dhhs to expand the use of
functional behavior assessments when
clinically indicated yeah so is that is
that the cost driver right there is that
the thing that that's okay correct so
senator
yes sir i'm i have almost no time
and um and and i really need to see
numbers before um i i am comfortable
voting for this
so
um
in case we don't get the numbers in time
what what i'm thinking we could do
is
is delete this paragraph
6 on line 21 through whatever 24
from the house version and since it's in
the senate version we could take it to
committee a conference and that would
buy us time
to get better math
how how do you react to that
uh if that's what you feel like you need
to do to move the bell then you know
that's fine and i guess you know we will
deal with it in committee of conference
i'll defer to you on strategy
um all right well
if we go to committee a conference it's
a partnership so um so representative
walner you have things to say
well i was just gonna ask um
when do you think you can have the um
cost
for us sometime today is that was that
what i understood
yes we've done some preliminary work and
just need to wrap it up but we should be
able to get some ballpark numbers to
kevin today
i mean personally before i make any
decisions about
taking this paragraph out i would like
to see
something about the cost
okay so
uh i think we've done about all we can
at this point
uh i i want to recess 416 and we'll pick
it up tomorrow
hopefully we'll wait a second
just before we do could we could we get
some agreement or get a measure of
whether there is agreement on the small
change to line 15 because i think that
should be in there regardless of which
way we decide to go with the other
pieces so so what i was thinking about
that is that should if if we ended up
wanting to remove
section four
i'd rather do both those things in one
amendment because the amendment you
suggested didn't seem controversial i
completely agree i want to know if it's
let's confirm that it's not
controversial not do anything just
confirm here
i'm good with uh representatives
amendment okay
so i'm becoming more perceptive and
sensitive with age i think
but okay so i so i i don't want to keep
throwing things at kevin and lls unless
we uh have a good cause so so so we'll
we'll recess 416
until tomorrow with the idea that
sometime within the next few hours we'll
get some math on this
representative edwards yes ma'am if we
if uh miss ross was able to
have
figures or some information
later this afternoon could that be
distributed to us before we leave here
today i i would love that i just don't
want to put any more pressure on them
you know uh so
the the sooner the better i think is the
case and and if we haven't recessed the
the whole work group today
since this bill is recessed i think we
could pick it back up if we get more
data
thank you
that brings us to
the bill i've been told i should not
call the omnibus
uh
so the not omnibus build um
uh sb 430
has many many items in it
and uh representative irf over the
weekend uh walked through them
um
before
we get started with sort of the earth
driven discussion of this uh 430
do you all have any specific sections of
430 that you you already know you'd like
to have discussed
it's it's a big bill
i think this is why
it took hhs 11 and a half hours to go
have their hearings
i would like to not do that
yes
i i would like to see us focus on ones
that have financial impact
and not on strictly policy issues
i i i'm generally okay with that i i
just have not sorted these and so i'm
i'm basically asking have you sorted
these into
fiscal and non-fiscal and do you have a
list of the fiscals you want to talk
about no but i bet representative erf
has
earth's pretty great so um so why don't
we
i know that he wants to talk about
uh paragraphs 3
6 22 and 55. is that right
that is correct and one of those is
policy but the other three are all
fiscal
are are there any other paragraphs to
add to that discussion not that i pulled
out a notice
uh 3
6 22 and 55.
okay so um
this is uh i did do um
a discussion draft i think on paragraph
three and so
when you when you think we're ready to
talk about that i'll uh what we can hand
those out
okay
and i'll give harry one and then you get
one
and then i get one
and you get one
you
give this a
i do have what i think is that same
language in the form of a formal
amendment would you like me to hand that
out now or not oh um
you so you took this and made it a
formal amendment if the if the language
that you passed out was in your email
the other day that yes yes yes i have
that oh well let's do that then and i
also have today we issued a revised
fiscal note for the bill as amended by
the house so i'll hand that out on 4 30.
yes
okay please
so i'm going to just do a general
overview on on what
uh amendment 1743
does to paragraph or section three of uh
of sb430
uh
we all know that we're supposed to do
ready aim fire
this this bill feels like a fire ready
aim um because we're gonna
charge
that a pilot program gets started uh
just immediately is authorized to just
go
and i don't
i don't know the extent to which any
planning for this pilot project
has been done
so i the inserted language
uh which is a little hard actually if
you've got my copy of the word document
it kind of it may be helpful because it
the bold shows you
uh
what what changes got made between the
section and the uh this amendment this
amendment is just to replace all so you
can't really see what got changed um
i um
so so what i did was um
essentially say
uh that there should be a planning phase
and then after the planning phase then
the um then the people who are doing the
pilot project planning can come to the
joint fiscal committee
and ask for permission to begin
execution
of the pilot program
i thought that might be necessary to
have
a more successful pilot and have us
understand
better
what the costs of it may be
i'll let you just read it if you unless
you want to go line by line on the
changes
a a key item is on six where it's in
bold if the department determines that
all necessary coordination for the pilot
program has been sufficiently completed
the department may make a request of the
joint legislative fiscal committee to
begin conduct of the pilot program upon
an appropriate effective date the pilot
program shall not begin until approval
of the joint legal or legislative fiscal
committee so they could do that
very early in the in this process or
later if they need more time to really
feel like they've got their plan where
they want it
any thoughts
you still put the money in there
uh i think i think the money said it
would uh lapse if not spent right
so so the the funding is available they
can they can do the
so the fiscal committee would be allowed
or able to let them start because the
appropriation would already be there
and and anything that's not spent should
lapse
is that is that clear to you and the way
uh
we've got a paragraph six written
well in seven it actually does say that
the appropriation shall be non-lapsing
and continually appropriated to the
department
so we could have that redrafted with
that section removed if you yeah i i i
should have caught that i would want
that to be uh lapse
uh representing
walls thank you mr chairman
just trying to understand why we're
doing this
because
i and i don't know this is not my
bellywood i'm not familiar with the
details in this but in looking at this
nobody in hhs raised these concerns
and i'm wondering if
a pilot program basically there's one
out there that they can sort of pick up
and not the program they can just pick
up and drop in it's been done elsewhere
it's it's not something that's novel
and
we don't need to try a pilot program
before we run the program because
everybody knows what the program needs
to be
and and there's nobody here to testify
i'm i don't know i'm just asking
why are we doing it this way i i think
you've actually raised a very good
question you and i are both making
assumptions your assumption is a happy
one in that the they already know how to
do this pilot program from other
examples and they're ready to go
mine is the more cynical
having never seen a pilot project
get rolled out quickly and effectively
i just i'm just trying to make sure that
we have an effective approach
is there anyone in the department who's
able to speak to
the maturity of the planning for this
pilot program
i also want to clarify representative
edwards i'm not making the assumption i
split the preface is by saying i don't
know
i'm just trying to look at it
analytically and think
you know if it ain't broke don't fix it
why are we trying to fix something that
nobody's come to us and said there's a
problem
we're about to hear if it's fixed or not
so mr williams could you
yes uh john williams the director of
legislative affairs for the new
hampshire department of health and
services thank you
um on section three of the bill
that section actually was generated as
part of last year's legislation senate
bill 162 which required the department
to engage key stakeholders in
developmental services
to develop a plan moving forward to
address the issue of children who are
age 18 up to 21 who although in need of
developmental services are outside of
the school
districts for responsibility for paying
for those costs so this is to fill in a
gap for those services for that age
cohort
the plan was developed by working
together with this group
and eventually translated into the
legislation you see before you uh with
the cap of 20 individuals that's what
the department estimates will likely be
the outside of the cap of those being
served with an understanding that there
would be a robust report that would have
to be developed and provided to both the
house and senate finance committees as
well as the policy committees on the
metrics before we take the next steps
building this into the 2425 budget
oh i'm a man of fewer words
so you're saying yes this pilot program
is ready to go
yes
okay
thank you it's been a joy working with
you for the last six years uh okay so
would you tell me uh tell us
it sounded to me like you just said that
you guys think that there's probably
only 20 eligible individuals to begin
with and and so when you pick 20 for
this pilot program that's nearly the
universe of the people that need the
program
did i did i mishear that or how big of a
potential population do we think will be
served once this program has established
itself as is effective
so pending this very important pilot
moving forward our department has worked
collaboratively to address the
behavioral rather the developmental
service needs of
children within that age cohort we've
been doing it on an ad hoc a one by one
basis uh the last i heard within the
last six months numbers were around five
or six individuals that we've recently
served however as you develop a pilot
like this the need and demand will have
to be reassessed as we move forward
because it could be
either a larger number of individuals
who may seek and need these particular
services the reason why i was capped at
20 was a reasonable number balancing out
as to what we expect to be participating
in the pilot program these are very
costly services and so there needed to
be some level of cost containment
and that we settled on the cap of 20.
could there be as many as 100 who would
need this program once we establish its
effectiveness
we will need to further assess that
through the pilot itself to give those
numbers to you for a projection uh
around that there have been others
outside of the agencies who have
suggested higher numbers uh but what
we're seeing from the numbers that we're
currently serving we believe that we can
service at least those who are in need
uh at the present time within the
context of this pilot of a kappa 20.
so so we're
going to incorporate the universe of
known people who need this service and
that happens to be about 20.
i believe i suggested earlier that we're
working on an ad-hoc basis uh one by one
that the numbers were uh uh smaller than
that i believe i mentioned five or six
okay so 20 is probably a
very safe number then well assuming
you're going to have four years from the
18th birthday to the 22nd birthday
you're going to have those five you're
aging out
okay so so my concern in the in
exploring the 20 is if the population's
bigger then the future program's going
to be more expensive that's one point
the the second point was if the
population is bigger and we're only
servicing 20 i'd be worried about
selection to make sure that the
selection process was fair
and and not favorites
so so it sounds to me like i don't need
to worry about a really big program nor
that favoritism was used to pick the 20
eligible beneficiaries
that is correct
all right mr chairman uh yes
representative walls um so as some of
you know i've been sitting on education
lately as well as in here and elsewhere
and one of the bills moving through
education is a bill that basically
expands services for disabled children
between the ages of 18 and 22.
and
i can get into the details of it but let
me just say that the way it's running i
think
it's unlikely that you're gonna see a
hundred kids in this you're gonna see
much more than what you've got because
the bill basically makes it easier for
kids to continue to get services
through the school year in which they
turned 22
and there were two different versions
i'm struggling to remember the version
that finally came out of the committee
whether it was on their 22nd birth oh i
believe it was at the end of the term
that they turned 22. so that kids can
stay in the program even longer and get
services so long as they don't graduate
and if they graduate then they're out
but the belief is is that a lot of these
disabled kids would choose not to
graduate so that they could continue to
get services through the school district
to the end of the term where they turned
22. so we're talking the same age
population here i just want to let you
know that there's in other words they're
expanding services on the educational
side which may impact and lessen the
services on the hhs side that's what i'm
trying to say
thank you hey representative erf do you
do you have anything you want to add to
this paragraph
ah thank you mr chair um well i would
either delete it
or at least make the funds lapsing as
opposed to non-lapsing which they are
now
that silence you hear is is me thinking
um
so i think i want to ask mr ripple to
just do a very simple amendment to this
section to make the funds lapsing
yep and i i think that would be
accomplished just by removing the
sentence that says it shall be
non-lapsing because the default
assumption is if there's no language
then the funds will lapse
i i'd be fine with that so
um so let's take a straw poll
would
the members of this committee be willing
to accept an amendment
that makes these
this 2.8 million dollars
lapsing versus non-lapsing
if you are in favor of an amendment like
that you'll raise your hand and then
i'll ask the opposite
but with the funds if if the program is
ready as mr williams seems to indicate
the funds could be spent immediately
the spending could begin immediately i
don't think they could spend it all
immediately
right this is this is this is not where
you're gonna write one big check you're
going to uh dole out money on a more
periodic basis i believe
that is correct
okay so the issue of lapsing versus
non-lapsing is relevant uh i believe so
um would you accept an amendment to make
these funds
lapse
as opposed to remain non-lapsing please
raise your hand
okay that looks unanimous those that
would
not want the amendment raise your hand
i'm not seeing any
so so let's uh let's draft that
amendment and then i think we can
dispose of this pretty quickly tomorrow
um
just just for confirmation if we had the
amendment
would you be in support of
paragraph three as amended raise your
hand please
okay um very good super straw vote
with that uh we're going to close or
it's no we're not we are going to move
within 4 30
to s you want to go to 22 first
so why don't you do 22 because you
actually know it better than i do so
representative erf is now going to talk
to us about
uh section 22.
okay
so
section 22 and i'm doing this from
memory now i'm not looking at the bill
essentially it's redefining the term
personal care attendant
under medicaid rules a personal care
attendant is basically a home healthcare
worker
and under the and i'm sure uh
mr lipman will correct me if i'm wrong
under the existing
state of emergency
and associated waivers
such as they are
family members can serve in that role
and be
paid basically
and there's some possibility that after
the state of emergency ends
and or additional waivers can't be
garnered and again mr lippman can
address this more accurately
um
there'd be a need for monies to continue
to pay
to continue that program going
and my suggestion would be just to let
the program end
and things go back to as they were
before this whole state of emergency
where family members took care of their
family members
without being paid for that
so um
as i i'm going to ask you to talk to
this mr libman but as i understand the
history of this
if we flash back about 10 years ago
people who needed at home uh care
had to go find a visiting nurse or
somebody like that and with
the shortages on visiting nurses and the
expenses of visiting nurses
uh it was it became perceived that it
would be cost effective if there was a
family member that could take care of
that member it was better to just go
ahead and pay that member to take that
family member to take care of the sick
person
because it was a good economic buy and
it helped strengthen families
and all of that sounds good
is that an accurate summary of the
history because then i want to keep
talking if it is
the record henry lipman medicaid
director in part it is mr chairman um
there's the the waivers like the
the home and kimmy based service waivers
this is also there's state plan services
which have
also have a component and
the issue at hand here is that
we find ourselves in a position where
there isn't a workforce they're entitled
to the a benefit
if
if the family members don't step up in a
certain situation we could end up where
um the state has exposure or
kids could be
kids or others could be
institutionalized and
incur a logic expense what we're
proposing here is
um
under the
as the vice chair said was under the
public health emergency we were able to
get a special waiver we're trying to
negotiate
another way right now with cms we're
concerned whether we'll get in place in
time and we could end up having a cliff
and so what we're asking for is in the
event we're not able to get something
else in place is to have
uh monies available so that we don't
have a cliff we have some time to get
something in place
that being said you know to the extent
that we didn't use it it certainly would
lapse i just want to make that that
clear
okay um
so
with all of that in in place before the
committee uh i i still come back to my
concern i've always felt this was
probably a pretty good idea and it was
compassionate and it solved the problem
but i have always wondered because i'm a
cynical individual has anyone conducted
the due diligence to ensure uh fraud
protection is built into the program and
that we're actively avoiding fraud in
this program because it just seems
susceptible
to the potential for fraud could you
talk to us about that
yes um i think in terms of the
amount of care that's allowed to be
provided that that's established in
advance
with a prior authorization
that in some instances here families are
entitled to private duty nurse a full
registered nurse
but
there isn't a workforce to be able to
provide that
family members can fill in for for some
of it the non
the non uh board of nursing approved
levels of service where you don't have
to be licensed so the families are
getting less than what they're
if you will been assessed to to need and
what they're technically a title
entitled to so i guess in terms of the
the there's no more than 50 percent of
what is
is determined as necessary can be
provided by the family in terms of
compensation
second level is before someone can
take on this role they have to be
screened as any other provider
we use grant state independent living to
to if you will on board them like any
other
lna who might provide the services as an
example
and um they're monitoring you know to
make sure that the
that the hours are documented whatever
and that what we're paying for is
actually been uh delivered but that's i
think we do have
appropriate controls here it's not just
you can decide to do what you want to do
as much as you want there's specific
limits set in advance
has this program ever been audited
um well it hasn't been um
audited in a formal sense yet um but the
it's under our managed care
um structure and so that the mcos in
terms of processing claims have whatever
they would ordinarily do
we certainly will
you know
look at this
demonstration if you will
and
again my concern is what happens if we
just sort of
let go with no you know end up having a
cliff here in terms of what happens to
to these situations because some some
people have been in put in a position
where
the a child's needs can't be met
um so they've you know maybe stopped
working um so that their child's needs
are met and then
so if we take that away they both don't
have employment and they're not getting
and i think we could end up with some
some concerns in terms of what the
state's position in terms of adequacy of
of care here
question
yes of mr littman
how many families are using this at this
time do you know
in the
in the state plan side of it i think
we're talking under 100 families
any any other questions
okay mr chairman uh representative walls
um
i seem to remember reading a newspaper
about some families who had their care
cut off they were not being paid by the
states and they ended up staying home to
care for their disabled family member
and ended up having to go on public
assistance
it's are you aware of those kinds of
cases out there
thank you for the question
i don't have the those press accounts
but what you described is
likely could happen
i think is the case because you know
given the choice of
you know
an example of a child who may need to uh
maybe um have a trach and need to have
you know regular care or something like
that with disabilities that they just
they're not in a position where they can
do nothing and so
that they could end up where you
describe for sure
mr ripple question for you
on page seven
line three
there is hereby appropriated to dhhs
700 000.
i'm not seeing the word lapsing or
non-lapsing so that means that the
default is that these are lapsing funds
that's correct okay
all right so
um is there are there any more questions
go ahead representative walter well i
did want to ask mr litman so
if a family um
did
lose this reimbursement and they
had to make the decision that they would
have to have their family member go into
a state a facility that the state would
then be responsible for
so
what is the range of costs for those
kinds of facilities
um
you know you're talking
numbers that you know are more than what
it costs for a nursing home stay for
an individual you know depending on you
know like a child with that i described
it as you know
a trach dependent and
um you know
high medical needs it's
i don't know that it would reach 700 000
based on a number that would do there
but you know there's also i think in
terms of exposure
from legal standpoint in terms of not
meeting needs in the least restrictive
environment
representative
so can you explain what was happening
prior to the state of emergency
so i think the
in terms of the the workforce situation
in terms of number of lnas that
that left the workforce or went to
different spots i mean we lost
um somewhere i think it was reported in
the union leader um you know like 1500
um
lnas dropped out of the workforce in
terms of providing services so i think
can comment with the
the
public health emergency covert situation
what have you that
there wasn't you know there was always
some challenge but it became a major
challenge um
in terms of meeting meeting needs and
you know i think
as it is today we're we're we're kind of
on the edge and i'm concerned about
getting pushed over the edge honestly
okay so i personally am um predisposed
to approving this
but i would like to take a straw vote
and
i'm going to ask it the same way if if
you're in favor of
leaving section 22 and sp 430 as is
raise your hand
my recollection is we've always done
this to some extent
all right so uh we probably don't really
have any action on this because we're at
some point going to vote on 430 but
as a whole but we've removed the
concerns around 22.
do you have a preference of which one
you want to talk about next
we're going to move to
item 55
55 55 55
is on page 15
midway down
do you want to do you want to start us
off do you want the department to talk
about this how do you want to proceed
well basically just yeah the department
come up it's basically this is
increasing medicaid reimbursement rates
for birthing services and it seems to me
that's the kind of thing we would do in
the budget year next year
yeah and uh that's true i'd like to hear
about that and i'd also want to hear
about this 25
figure because that you know the at
first
glance that seems like a very hefty
percentage and then
you give yourself the flexibility to
give different rates based on different
geography and i'm just curious what this
what the methodology and thoughts would
be there
so you go for it
again for the record henry medicaid
director
um this bill was originally senate bill
401 proposed by senator bradley
there's
um
and senate bill 401
the senate used that for
um
in
finance changed that bill to be the
property tax relief bill in terms of
some bridges roads and and this is where
they ended up
putting this component um
and
frankly where we where we are with
obstetric services in the state um
is we
we did not budget for this in um
because we had the the rate increases in
20 and 21 the two 3.1 percent increases
but just the the base in which
a berth is paid for is off a base that's
around two thousand dollars so twenty
five percent on two thousand dollars is
what we're talking about for a whole
um inpatient stay drg payment
um
the the reason that the department
strongly supports this is that we've
seen 10
hospital closures of obstetric services
in the north country in particular um
we're we're left with a very
small network that
has during the public health emergency
gopher had to come through with some
money to keep
littleton um afloat in terms of
maintaining their service they were
ready to drop it as well
um a result of finances
and
in terms of what
losing like a littleton or
or berlin
in particular as two examples would
create a major geographic hole in terms
of providing services
and
we're already starting to see with the
closures that have already
happened
more unplanned out of
out of hospital births
we're
we're concerned that what this proposal
does is just it buys us some time to
work on a longer term plan because this
isn't going to be enough to do it and i
think what i've talked to the senate
about
senate finance is you know the the large
sums of money we're putting into for
example rebuilding the mental health
system particularly in patient capacity
that once you lose this obstetrics
capacity to try to re-establish it and
it is needed both from not just a
healthcare delivery standpoint but if if
you talk to the economic development
folks in terms of the north country as
an example that
um you know without a hospital
delivering burst you you got your
demographics are set in a way that you
know they're already tough up there in
terms of just being an old population
so
i understand why you'd prefer to see it
in a
in a budget approach but i think we'll
be coming back in the budget you know
with hopefully a longer range plan than
what this does this i think buys this
time so we don't deal with more closures
represent weiler
as i recall new hampshire now has more
deaths than births so we've seen him
obviously from looking at the
demographics in the schools we're seeing
a much smaller number of and so what
percentage would you estimate if it's
anything like what we're seeing in the
school population it's like five percent
every year less
of the births so
i think we've been in the upper 11 000
total births in the state um i think
around 11 7
um 11.7 11 700 approximately you know
we've been around
a little bit above 12 000 previously
there was i think just an article in the
paper today i think front page of the
monitor about a concern of a spike in
uh births related to what's
people getting back to sort of
planning life if you will um
but you know up in the north country in
terms of the medicaid percentages
whereas it's just about twenty five
percent of the birth statewide are our
medicaid it can approach forty percent
um and i think even a couple occasions
fifty percent of the births depend on
medicaid in order to deliver the service
and getting paid
you know something that is
probably less than
half of what commercial um
uh
insurers are paying in in some cases
more than three times less
you know i think that those hospitals
that
are more dependent on medicaid need a
little extra help and that's why
the bill also has that provision that
you asked about representative edwards
which is the commissioner to be able to
target some of this funding so those
that are most vulnerable but would have
a base amount so that all
all the remaining hospitals are able to
continue i think that base amount was 20
and because there's a relatively small
amount of births
um in the
rural hospitals is there's enough to to
do that plus to to give an extra amount
to the to the north country and um also
there's the western part of the state
too
okay so just generally my concern any
time there's discretion is it be applied
in a
transparent and and fair manner but
that that's for all of these sorts of
things was it your testimony that a
normal newborn the medicaid
reimbursement rate right now is about
two thousand dollars per delivery yes
for normal i don't i don't know how they
do it for anywhere near that and then
and then so obviously if there's a an
icu incident that's got to be more
um but uh and so medicaid's probably uh
cutting corners there too on uh the nicu
yeah i think you know we've done a lot
recently to
buttress mental health including um for
involuntary admissions our reimbursement
has gone significantly up
what i think you know
today what we're faced with if we don't
do something we're so low that we end up
creating something much more expensive
for us to deal with down the line here
so it's 25 enough
i think it's enough to buy us some time
to because there are some things that i
think are going on the state in terms of
studies of how maybe delivery models
could evolve and
you know i think it's our intent to to
work with
with the
the greater community that's delivering
babies to look at what the options are
because it's not just money it's also
workforce and making sure that you know
there's enough workforce and backup
available um
and so i think we
we do need this
um preferentially now um to avoid
further closure and then
to to look on a more comprehensive plan
um
and i really do think that the north
country you know seen some
some benefit of
the pandemic if you will in terms of
increasing the
the
number of people that are in the
community that are of lower ages you
know balancing the demographics and i
think if you had uh taylor coswell here
he would he would support that um
strongly um
but
i'll leave it at that
okay so um
how about midwives do
do does midwifery get any
increase as a result of this so senate
bill
408 in terms of birthing centers um
provides for now i'm just talking about
what's in 430. in 430 no this is just
specifically for the institutional um
services in the hospital is that an
oversight should we add midwifery um
i think that
um in many instances
i think that we probably when we come
back we need to look at the professional
side of things um the obstetrician and
the
um the midwifery
so this is just the technical side not
the professional side
okay in many cases that
now providers are part of hospital
systems through employment or some other
contract i i do think that the whole
system of caring for
for newborns and
i don't i don't i don't mean to cut you
off it's just we got a lot of roads
still to go uh mr ripple i'm i'm i'm
reading
uh line 29 about the sum of 2.4 million
and similar to the last phrasing this
looks like these funds lapse
yes they would
okay so with that i i would just say uh
to the committee
do you have any questions anyone have
any questions
okay so uh i'm i'm predisposed to
supporting this um is there any
discussion around that because i'd like
to take a straw vote if uh
if there's no further discussion
it's 2.4
yes sir
okay so same thing if you're in favor of
leaving
this section alone in 4 30
without modification please raise your
hand
okay that looks unanimous
so we can skip over this uh then
thank you very much
um
now or do you think you're ready for six
i am
okay so we're gonna go
back in time
to page three
go go ahead
thank you mr chair
so if i understand this
section correctly
it's essentially eliminating an annual
report
and i had to read kind of deeply to get
into this on expanded
medicaid family planning services
which was being provided to the fiscal
committee and i have not been on that
committee very long so i haven't seen it
but
i actually would be interested in seeing
such a report on an annual basis so i
would suggest deleting this section so
that in fact
we would get an annual report on the
expanded medicaid family planning
services to the fiscal committee so as i
understand your point on line 23 where
there's a strikethrough of the words and
annually thereafter making this you know
no longer an annual report
you would you would not want those words
stricken so that we would maintain this
as an annual report
i believe that's right i believe that's
what's necessary to achieve
the goal okay so i have a question on
the
earlier in line 12
is referenced july 1 2013 i just wanted
to make sure that wasn't a typo was it
really 213 and not 223 or something
john williams director of legislative
affairs and as you correctly point out
that's an existing law this actually
came from legislation from 2013
and part of our efforts here to
clean up outdated
reporting requirements this request was
made by director tilly from the division
for
public health we wanted to tread lightly
we understood the importance of the
remainder but we just wanted to remove
the annual reporting requirements since
we've been fulfilling that since the
2013 data okay mr williams i i
i don't i've been around and i've not
actually seen this report that i recall
and i'd uh i think as much
we fully funded the governor's family
planning services
and i suspect we'll continue to do that
but it would really be great to actually
get reports so i
personally in in favor of striking
through the strikethrough so that we can
keep the annual report
and the representative edwards if i
could respond just from a drafting
standpoint if that's the goal to keep
existing law then you'd be much better
off directing mr ripple to just removing
the section from the bill
because this represents existing law
all right so so i
so on the issue of deleting the annual
reporting requirement does
anyone on the committee
seem to want to get rid of the annual
reporting requirement or would you like
to see
what we're doing to deliver family
services planning services i would like
to see it come to some agency or some
committee because i've never seen it
normally these reports come to fiscal
i've never seen one
and and i've been on hhs oversight so i
haven't seen it there either but um so
so let's uh let's do a straw poll
because i'm not i'm not getting this
complete sense but
i
would like to maintain the requirement
to keep an annual report and it sounds
like the smartest way to do that is just
delete this section because the really
the only thing it does is delete the
three words in annually thereafter
so
do you guys want to talk about it
amongst yourself first or do you want to
just go for a straw vote
okay so um again we're gonna do two
votes uh first one will be
in this case
are you in favor of deleting lines 11
through 24 with the if i'm sorry 11 line
through line 24.
oh you're right it starts in line nine
nine through 24. so i i'm proposing that
we delete that so that we maintain the
annual requirement or if you are in
favor of deleting that section so that
the report remains annual you'll raise
your hand
i see everyone
okay so that's unanimous so mr ripple
can you make that happen yes
uh thank you
so
so i think we've talked about the four
sections of concern in 430 um
and so if that is the case and i'll let
you confirm it but what what i would
like to do though is because this is
just so thick there's so many issues
here uh is give everyone an opportunity
to come back
tomorrow and and we could we can still
pick out a section if you got an issue
with it so uh consider this an
all-you-can-eat buffet still
um with that uh
i think i'm ready to close 4 30.
um
mr ripple what do you think we've done
on 4 30
so i have two amendments so far one is
you would accept amendment 1743 h
however you would remove the non-lapsing
sentence to make it lapsing instead and
also you would remove section six
thank you that's the way i understood it
all right
so with that
we can move on to four 444
this is relative to the childhood
adverse experiences treatment and
prevention
and this is
representative walls has caught my eye
because this is another pilot program
kind of deal and i my working assumption
until i hear otherwise is
pilot projects need a lot of planning
for them to be effective and i'd like to
hear about the planning senator whitley
welcome back what do you want to tell us
thank you mr chair i appreciate the
opportunity to uh talk about this bill
so i admittedly this is a bit of a dense
bill there are a number of
programs and sort of clarifications in
here but the overall
purpose of the bill is to fill in a gap
in our existing children's system of
care so this legislature has done a
whole lot of work building the
children's system of care for children
with mental health
uh and um and also trauma and so
but there is a big there is a big gap in
services for young children
zero to five and so this bill looks at
the prevention side of the program
oftentimes we get families and children
when they are already in crisis when
they are in emergency rooms when they
are in out of state facilities and i am
often asked well how do we get these
families before
they get to crisis when they are the
most expensive and this is the way that
we do it we focus on the prevention side
so this is a really missing piece
of that puzzle
and it also recognizes that the impact
of trauma on young children is very
significant children are of course very
vulnerable to the impacts of trauma both
in how vulnerable they are just as young
children but also how it impacts their
brain but
the good news on that is that their
brains are very plastic
they are able to there's interventions
that we can do to mitigate the impacts
of trauma so that's what this bill
attempts to do so i'm happy to go
through the various parts um and answer
your questions as we go
so first i just want to ask you a couple
simple questions sure okay
um
so the the cornerstone of a zero to five
age group
dealing with prevention
the target population for education is
really are really the parents right so
so we're this program
at its core is intended to
educate parents to not abuse their
children in some way
and to avoid the the aces
uh
happening in the first place yes sir so
i you are absolutely correct that we
need to make sure we're to support young
children we need to support and educate
families i think to get exactly to what
you're talking about if you look at
section 9
is the arpa appropriation for family
resources centers we already have a
robust
regional structure of family resource
centers
they have received federal money in the
past that we need to leverage
um but we need those resource centers to
have what they need to support families
to prevent child abuse and neglect it's
called primary prevention
so so you have a lot of interesting
people in the senate so you've probably
heard somebody
raise the issue
of
is it appropriate for the government to
be intervening with parents
to parent them on how to parent is that
is that an appropriate role of
government have you heard that general
question and how would you answer it we
actually didn't get that question in the
senate i mean i think here all all these
are voluntary we're not forcing parents
to get interventions these are just you
know interventions that are available
should families need the support so
there's nothing mandatory about this i
think that's not that's not something i
believe the senate would support at this
point but these are the supports that
should be available and the treatment
that should be available if a family and
child needs it
thank you for that um
what what is your reasoning or how would
you argue
on why this shouldn't just be
incorporated in the next budget
uh well because children are in crisis
right now we have children that are you
know the the
pandemic has exacerbated a lot of things
including the children's mental health
crisis we have children in crisis right
now we can't wait any longer and we do
know i mean
this is one of the most horrific things
that i have heard recently during the
pandemic we have seen an increase in
child sex abuse for this age group so
this is a crisis that we can't really i
know it's horrific we can't really hold
off on
um the other piece to is it is it mr
chair is that we have the dollars
available right now through arpa dollars
those are discretionary dollars so there
are no
federal funds there are no excuse me
state funds appropriated so i'm sorry if
you look at the fiscal note it is
incorrect at this point there are four
appropriations listed
in the fiscal note but on the senate
floor we took out two of those so the
only remaining appropriations are number
two
seven hundred thousand and number four
one hundred uh one million so the other
two appropriations are gone and uh and
the remaining appropriations are
strictly arpa dollars so so mr ripple
are you aware of a update to the fiscal
note in works
uh we have i haven't yet updated that
one but
i can take a look and see if i can
provide an update for tomorrow
you agree with senator whitley's
observation though i do yes
all right so i i'm going to come to
representative erf in just a second i
got one more question for you
uh you just mentioned something heinous
that zero to five sexual abuse
and and we're talking about a voluntary
program
and i'm just curious if we think that
the depravity of a of a perpetrator in
this situation is just beyond
anything we can do on a voluntary basis
i mean i i i understand for everything
else for this is maybe a good program
but i just i i don't know if we're
setting as an objective to
or how we would even go about
trying to
remediate such a horrible problem yeah
you know i yes so in in new hampshire
you may know that we have both a
voluntary and if there's a finding of
abuse and neglect then that's a whole
different track for parents and you know
the director of dcyf can speak to that
so we have that when there's a finding
there that will be some sort of
mandatory things involved and then we
have a voluntary system
in terms of the impacts of child sex
abuse so part of this um
the the one of the remaining
appropriations is to expand the
workforce for child parent psychotherapy
that's an intervention for young
children to mitigate the impacts of
horrific trauma that we were just
talking about so i think it is
you know imperative that these children
that have been impacted by this horrific
trauma get the treatment that they need
to grow up into healthy adults so this
is what we're talking about here
it just seems that the treatment plan
would be to arrest in prison imprison
the perpetrator but um but anyway
anyways i don't want to get into all
that i do want to give representative
erf an opportunity to ask this question
so just one question
given these are all arpa funds couldn't
this just come through fiscal
there uh thank you for the question
there are some portions that did go
through fiscal for example there's a
pilot program in here that the
department has been working on um and
the authority is in in this language and
they did go through fiscal but these are
the remaining portions that have not
gone through fiscal and there isn't
really a plan to do so i i don't want to
misspeak about that
again for the record rebecca ross
director of the bureau for children's
behavioral health that's correct we did
have a fiscal item that was approved in
november of last year for 1.6 million
for the zero to five population these
are additional programs that were not
included in that it would codify
some portions of this permanently as
part of the system of care
so that's the reason he didn't go
through physical because you're there's
policy stuff in here that would become
part of the system of care correct
thank you i agree
are there any other questions
so these funds
these are arpa funds so
is there a user to lose it aspect of
this how long do we have to spend these
uh that is a good question i
so the dollars that we're talking about
here are not um sort of designated arpa
dollars they're arpa discretionary
dollars and maybe mr ripple can answer
that question i don't know when our
official requirement to spend is
do you know
i actually don't know that one off the
top of my head i'd have to check on it
all right so it's really just a
cautionary note to the department to
make sure that they get the program
the funds obligated before they run out
but
um okay so
i is are there any other questions i i
think um
i'm i'm generally uh predisposed to this
unless somebody tells me i'm not but i
think i am
uh is is
i'm ready for a strava are you all ready
for a strava okay so
if you're in favor of
of otp on sb 444 you'll raise your hand
i don't see anything anybody in
opposition
so i would like uh with your permission
uh representative walner i'd like to go
ahead and have the clerk call a roll
call on this are you okay with that yep
i'm fine so i'd move well i'll let some
of you we're going to need a motion in a
second
yeah
you you can motion this one is what
herpes say
[Laughter]
second
all right moved and seconded any further
discussion on represent or on
representative walner no or is there any
more discussion on senate bill 444
uh representative walls
i just looked up for you uh arbor funds
must be spent by december 31st 2026
oh okay super thank you
uh the clerk when you're ready you can
call a roll
motion is out to pass on senate bill 444
representative earth yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walner
representative long yes representative
walls yes
chairman edwards yes
voter 7-0 voter 7-0 uh
division three will recommend to the
finance committee that the otp
and
uh representative walner will write the
committee report
all right thank you uh
okay so that brings us down to the final
two but these final two are rather
significant so
i i would like to uh put us into recess
for about five ten minutes so that
everyone can stretch their legs and and
and kind of
re-ready themselves to to go through
this so
uh i have uh
the time now 2 50.
um let's let's get started no later than
three o'clock please
mr chairman
mr chairman you might want to know that
the official mr ripple just sent us
information on 416. i just saw it in my
email
okay
unless we can get started sooner
458.
so mr ripple you you do not have an
amendment for 458 right so we're just
going to use my discussion draft okay
which i do not i did not print out
copies of that for the members okay
so so i have three o'clock
is everyone ready to get started i i
probably ought to wait for mr ripple
he's probably secretly the most
important person in the room
so i i've given you a discussion draft
on
by that i mean i went through there and
i i made some markups to stimulate some
conversation
um
so mr ribson i i i'm
i'm i'd like you to sit at the
table so if we have questions that come
up
but uh because the committee
talked about 458 last friday
and and we have this discussion draft to
walk through
uh i i think i think the role i'd like
you to be prepared to play is to follow
along with us and and then if we have an
issue that we want to take a side track
on have you get engaged
do you but i want to respect do you want
any preparatory remarks before we we
start driving through this
for the committee i want to end by five
why do i want to end by five because
janet clayman
needs to leave and so we'd like to get
all our paperwork into janet so
um okay
so uh 458 an act relative to the
use services center and operation of a
replacement secure facility
the first
topic that we come through if we just go
chronologically
is
that um
i took
i took the senate's past version
and had begun to amend the sen the
version passed by the senate
i skipped over
and this is a little bit rude probably i
skipped over
the
version that got passed
out of the policy committee
and out and out of the house
why did i do that i did that because
i had
a sidebar
with
the governor
who said
to me that
he really liked the senate version
and that he could see himself signing
the senate version
so so i
have tacked towards the senate version
and then identified some things where i
know we're at odds
that we'll be at odds with the policy
committee
how bad is that well i don't know if you
listened to the um
the executive session on 458
in
children and family law
but
the chairman of the committee
basically said
that
i don't want to mischaracterize it so i
won't i
so this is not meant to be anything like
a quote but my interpretation of what
she said was we're going to do things
like reduce the capacity down to six and
then if finance thinks differently they
can negotiate it up
okay and
um and so i
also heard from
you were there
is is that a fair summary i don't i
it is okay
so um
then the other big thing
the house did
was they inserted a lot of language from
hb 254
254 passed the house went over to the
senate the senate
as i understand
has
gotten themselves in a position to
adopt
or to pass sb 254
with
what has been characterized as
some minor amendments
uh and those minor amendments
uh if nothing else addressed concerns
that were expressed
that if there was no consequence for
property crime
possible
that we would be invent inviting
property crime such as the smash and
grab types of things that we're seeing
i i i don't think there's any intent to
start taking kids
who have
participated in property crimes and
willy-nilly put them in the sununu
center now this is just a fallback i
think
and our judges if we look at the data
our judges have done a pretty good job
along with the legislature of reducing
the census over the last few years
um from 2019 to 2020
there's been an obvious trend down
to where
we see a lot of 11's and
10's towards the right side so that's a
daily census
so
so that
that's kind of a background that's me
trying to tee this up
um
so
the first issue that gets addressed
is the is the bed capacity
um
the uh
the
committee on children and family law
wanted to go to six instead of the 18
that was in hb2
it did not appear from watching the
executive session on the bill that there
was any data behind it it seemed as
though
it was a a hope and a prayer kind of
number
uh representative walner you and i had a
chance to talk briefly this weekend and
and you i think you have something you
may want to say on whether
6 12 18 or some other number is
right to you
well i do think that you know we've
we've done a lot in the last
several years to
reduce the uh
the
number of children that are housed at um
the sununu center and i think there's
still a few things that we can do to
continue reducing it
i do think it's interesting that
what we were handed out
to right just now
looks different than what i got in my
email
because when i got in my email today
i got something where it was divided by
detained
and committed and so when i look at
those numbers i think this is something
where it's all been lumped together so
it makes the numbers somewhat larger
also i do
pay attention to the dashboard
that we get monthly
and
i need to go find my february day or my
march dashboard but
i thought in the month of february the
dashboard actually said we were at eight
children
so
i i just wonder what the discrepancies
are with this this piece that we just
got
and what we received in our email
so what you receive your email is a
excel file that has three tabs on it
the first tab is the daily count of
every single day from january 1 2019
through today and it's a list that has
male female detained committed
the second tab is this chart which is
just a
chart format of the average daily census
of each of those months so if you took
all of those days and averaged them out
this chart shows that the third tab on
that excel spreadsheet has the same data
but just listed in a spreadsheet form
rather than in a chart
and i'm not sure i'm to answer your
second question
there's i'm certain that there were not
only eight youth at syse in february so
i'm not sure what that is i'll have to
look again and see i just i mean it
could just have been a typo so who knows
can i have another yes
go ahead
so
i guess for this
for our deliberations here today i would
like to and i guess everybody must have
gotten in their email
the uh
charts that were separated
i guess what i would
like to take a look at are the number of
committed
children
um as opposed to committed and detained
it seems like um
that sort of
inflates the number
can can i turn that into a specific
question uh so for example
on
uh december 1st of 2020
it shows a total daily population of 10.
can you tell us what the committed
versus detained were
in that month
so again the spreadsheet that i sent out
had one page with every single day so
december 1st 2020 there were let me just
pull this apart so i can see the header
so so i think you're just going to have
to eyeball it and give us a number first
2020 there were four detained females
zero detained males so total of four
detained on december 1st 2020
and there were a total of
let's see i'm trying to make sure i have
this lined up right on the printout
sorry
we're asking you to compare apples and
oranges though because you have daily
information and we have an average of a
month yeah and you have you have the
daily too it was in the spreadsheet that
i sent you i said i sent both the daily
and the monthly averages
i'm sorry i had that wrong december 2020
total detained
was four there were zero female detained
four male detained total committed was
five
there was one female committed and four
male committed on that date
total commitment was
on that date total committed five on
december one twenty
on that date on that one date right so
it varies so um
do you have a follow-up
no i just wanted to
point out that there are
two categories and i believe this chart
sort of lumps everyone together
and i think we need to look at
so let me ask you a question about that
is it your thought
that
we could reduce the population at sununu
more by simply having a different place
for detained versus committed
i think that would be that would be a
possibility
by using uh providers that we're already
using
the
so the way that syc currently operates
and the way that we anticipate a future
state operating is we no longer
programmatically distinguish between
detained and committed kids because the
numbers have gotten so small once upon a
time there was a detained unit separate
from the rest of the committed facility
as the numbers got so small it became
silly because sometimes you'd have one
kid in a detained unit and you'd have
you know so we got to the point where we
started mixing kids
by gender and by programmatic need
rather than by detention or commitment
status
just made much more sense operationally
because you condense the kids
in a way that you could you know have
sensible or at least something
approaching sensible staffing
the
idea of
moving detained kids out i think could
be challenging you still need a fully
secured
facility for detained kids a lot of
times the detained kids are actually
even more unstable and difficult to work
with than the committed kids although it
varies because we have kids that come in
with all types of needs and offenses
so you could do that but i i don't know
that while it might reduce the size of
that facility you would then need a
separate facility that you were paying
somebody else to run or that the state
was running
so the approach
and there's no legislation now telling
you to segregate detain from committed
and therefore at this point if we're
using existing legislation it is an
aggregate number right
that's correct okay
so um so the first thing i did was
where in the senate bill it said 18 beds
i added
that the facility is at least 14 beds
but no more than 18.
and then
i direct that the commissioner dhhs
shall conduct a data analysis to
determine the bed capacity to be used
for future architectural designs using
pan's past census trends and expected
census impacts of current legislation
and to do that no later than july 31 of
this year
the department will prioritize locating
the well we'll stop there because this
is that's really the point of that
is to say
rather than make this a legislative
effort to just
grab a number i i would hope that we
would agree that data analysis is the
appropriate way to set the capacity
and and that
we we can trust and defer to the
commissioner the process of doing a data
analysis to pick the number
we up we i think we're kind of around
the same ballpark 18 was in hp2
maybe this data suggests it doesn't need
to be as much as 18 except for the fact
that
you never know when you're going to get
a weird surge you're never going to know
when you're going to need to have a
unique division of male female
and
separations due to things like gang
status and the like so so some surge
capacity does seem to make sense above
just a hard number
but i'm i'm comfortable
um delegating
to the professionals
the actual
size between that range
do you guys want to talk about that
what do you think representative long
thank you mr chairman uh with respect to
senate bill 254
now we know there's a couple of areas
that are problematic
would that
would some of that language decrease
detained
i'm
i am not comfortable predicting that
that's going to necessarily decrease the
census and for the reasons i spoke about
last time because what
the
the original original version of 254
prior to the one that passed the house
retains something that was that's in
current law which is three lesser crimes
could still have a child go to syc and
that's actually the way that most kids
who go to sysc end up there after
multiple charges not after a first
offense the way that 254 changed that in
one of the amendments in the current
version that's over in the senate was it
eliminated that kind of pathway but
added in a new pathway based on
community safety and community risk
which is a policy i don't necessarily
think is a bad
shift but i am not i'm not able to
predict that that's going to result in
less kids in the facility
and i think you know it's it's risky to
assume that that's going to result in
less kids in the facility i just i don't
know that it will and i'd be it could
result in more kids i mean i just don't
i don't know how that's going to play
out compared to the current the current
pathway that's fair thank you
we're representing wyler
thank you mr chair but detained
so the ones that are not detained can we
assume that they've been bailed
no there's not there's not bail um in
the juvenile system when kids are
detained
typically they go in for it could even
be a couple days while things are sorted
out there could be weeks while things
are sorted out or if there's
complexities they could be in detained
status for
i've seen kids in ordinary detained
status for three or four months while
they're waiting for certification
processes and things like that and even
longer and when kids go in as adults we
categorize them as detained so when kids
go in because they've been charged and
and found guilty of an adult level
offense and they remain with us until
they turn 18 in that instance those all
fall into the detained category the
commitment category is following
adjudication when a determination is
made that
the youth committed whatever offense and
the way that law currently works most
offenses result in what is a three-month
time in a commitment status followed by
a parole hearing
at which point most of the young people
do get out after three months committed
status and then we'll move on to whether
it's back home or residential program or
some other option and then some of the
more serious offenses could be a six
month prior to parole
yeah because the lawyers are defending
and delaying and all that sort of thing
but so this is unusual to have these few
and detained i guess
yeah you know what's really interesting
is
you know that and if you look at that
day by day data and really did analysis
you would see there was a period where
we had more detained kids than committed
kids
but now we've seen that kind of flip
back again not by a lot a couple more
committed a couple more to team but it's
no you know if you look at the
historical data going back 20 years
you're seeing
120 committed kids and 20 detained kids
and now we're seeing about
ballpark
six and six five and five
unpredictable so so i would imagine that
financial
disclosure that you hear sometimes about
past performances not indicative of the
future performance that that applies
here too right i mean we can do a great
data analysis but it's sort of difficult
to foresee
how well that trend will hold up in the
long term and we're building a facility
for what 20 30 years at least
i'd imagine so okay
so
um
so i i don't want to call anyone out by
name but i've heard
a member of this committee say that the
the bad count should be
six
does anyone want to talk about the
number six
if if mine's if mine's the name you want
to call i'll feel free i'm glad to speak
to it i've told you i don't support your
amendment
that's fine i have time to find another
vice chair
[Music]
representative walner
could i ask uh rep
representative um mr ripson another
question
so
could you
tell me how many
group home beds you are contracted for
at this point
uh rebecca ross can probably give the
exact number but it's
probably 400 or so around the state
you have any idea how many children are
in those beds
i think point-in-time data is probably
somewhere around 300 and change right
now
and do i understand that
maybe within the last
year and a half or so we went to
governor council with contracts
and that we've changed our way of paying
we don't pay any longer
per day we now pay by contract
so you're contracting for a certain
number of beds at a facility is that
right not not quite so we did shift to a
contracted model for the first time
about a little over a year ago or in
some instances a little less than a year
ago those contracts were finalized the
reasoning for that was
prior to that all these providers were
basically operating on they had to meet
minimum basic medicaid rule standards
and that was kind of the extent of how
we were able to
to derive what it was we wanted from
these providers and we we wanted a lot
more than what we were getting so we we
created different levels of care with
different intensities
different requirements such as becoming
accredited programs utilizing models
such as
six core strategies to reduce restraint
and seclusion etc and we entered into a
contract with the providers for that
purpose put it out for a public bid
everything else the contracts still do
set a daily rate however so they still
do get paid on a daily rate basis for
the kids that they're serving
but the rates through those contracts
were enhanced to actually match what we
were asking them to do as opposed to the
historical model which people had their
rates set once and then they were stuck
stagnant
for in some instances 12 13 years
yeah okay just one more question okay um
so we
have the capacity of 400 beds
we're probably around 300
at any one time
yeah there's probably about that many
under contract with about 300 or so that
are currently filled i would be careful
to say capacity because one of the
challenges we've been seeing
really since the start of covid but for
different reasons is providers not being
able to actually have the amount of
available beds that they are required to
enter their contracts initially because
of separation rules they had under covid
currently has much more to do with
workforce capacity and not feeling they
can safely operate to the full capacity
of their contract
so
we could say i mean i'm sure that of
those hundred beds that
aren't
that are not filled at any one time it
might be hard to fill all of the i mean
it might be hard to get the um group
homes to be able to take all
all of those because
of
staffing and a number of different
things
but there is some capacity in group
homes at this point i assume
i think there's wait lists at most of
them but yes on paper there's capacity
whether there's you know actual
availability today to take a child i
think the big distinguishing point that
i would make though is that
um
right we don't maintain discretion over
whether a child is detained and
committed that's that's a court's
decision as to whether a child is
detained or committed or put into
residential care what we do have the
authority to do and which we do
regularly
is if a child comes to us committed we
do have the authority to
administratively administratively
release a child to a residential program
if we think the residential program is
better suited we do that pretty
regularly um
so we often do see kids move from these
facilities from from sysc onto
residential programs
but in the first instance we're not the
deciding body of courts the deciding
body as to where that child is going to
go um
i think
yeah i'll leave it at that okay thank
you so so these census numbers in other
words uh reflect those that you you kept
and do not include those that you moved
into an alternative group home
correct yeah there's no
these are the numbers of the kids are
actually in the building excluding the
kids under the vermont contract they're
not included in these numbers thank you
so so this is really to the committee
and it's kind of a two-part question
are you are you comfortable delegating
to the commissioner the authority to do
the quantitative or the data analysis to
establish a bed capacity
and if you are
are you comfortable with this range of
selecting between 14 and 18. would you
prefer
12 to 20 which i you know i i picked 18
of 14 to 18 based on
sitting in my comfy chair typing
so i'm i'm open to
some conversation there
i'm listening to the
director and i think he's got you know
the numbers in his head every day
more than any of the rest of us could
come up with and i think from his
testimony
he's comfortable
so part a of that is you're you're
comfortable delegating to the commission
or the authority to pick the final
number
i am
do you uh part b do you do you you think
the 14 to 18 range gives the
commissioner enough
flexibility or would you
prefer a different set of numbers
i'm hopeful it could go less than 14 but
if it goes higher what are we going to
do and you know i
i'd also like us to look at the option
of using more of the private
uh group homes and and
having some of them maybe come up to a
uh
i guess it's stage four level of uh
security
okay
so mr ripple at this point um what i
would what i would do before this became
an amendment
uh and there's so much more to it than
this but just the beginning
is to change the 14 to 12.
okay okay
um
i'm not hearing anyone say no to
delegating to the commissioner
i you know certainly respect
uh mr ripson's
information but i think really it's it's
the legislature right now that's making
the decision
what what number would you select
i would select six
representative walls
representative long you have an informal
voting going on over there
what do you think about delegation of
the commissioner and what the number
should be yeah i mean i did support the
six in the policy committee
um i
it may be a dream
uh
i mean the more i listen to mr ripson
the more i see that
my six may not be the correct number
um but
i
i just want to be assured that we're
doing everything that we can
to be sure that if there's a program
in a community or
a service somewhere else
that that child gets that
that child gets that service and not be
detained since you were in children and
family law
was
the number six derived
from a data analysis perspective or
was that
a number that was perhaps aspirational
as opposed to databased
uh
i mean i could only speak for myself
and it was aspirational
for me
all right thank you
uh representative
at this point i do still support the six
mr chairman
representative walls yes
so this has been worked on multiple
terms multiple years and these numbers
have been examined there have been
working
the number of of the appropriate number
of beds has been studied with multiple
advocacy groups the department a lot of
people have looked at this over a long
time this is not something that is
aspirational this is this is based on
data and you know the disability rights
center legal
uh services
you know uh who we heard from before
michelle ranger and other people have
been involved in this in setting this up
and i feel like we're kind of sitting
here right now
shooting by the seat of our pants really
just relying on the testimony of mr
ribson when there's been a lot of other
information that came in um and it's
been a situation where we have seen over
and over again kind of
there were two things that contributed
to the large numbers of kids
incarcerated at sununu one was the size
of the facility if you build it they'll
come the other one was the can the the
laws under which kids could be committed
um as we have reduced the crimes for
which kids can be committed
we've watched those numbers drop
i mean there's been a whole complex of
things that have been going on
really since we raised the age of
delinquency in 2014. they have really
worked hard now
what would that make that about eight
years
of working on this and
you know there's a reason we're at six
it's not just people shooting by the
seat of the pants and and i'm concerned
that we've got one witness here we're
not hearing from all the people that
have worked on this year after year
after year from all the people that have
been on the study committees that have
come up with these numbers and studied
this and determined this really is a
realistic number and we're doing this
here on really very limited information
and that's why i'm staying with six so
so my understanding is
actually the opposite that all the
analysis that we've seen year after year
after year from the alvarez and marcel
study to what got into hb2
is that
in order to give us the flexibility
needed the number was 18.
and i i i'm
expressing some interest in entertaining
the possibility of a lower number but
six is an imaginary as far as i'm
concerned that is a total aspirational
stab in the dark and i just am
embarrassed at the lack of data analysis
that would determine the number six we
have a public safety responsibility and
and i think if we put six in there that
is an abdication of our responsibility
and i will not
allow six to be the number uh
if i have anything i can do about it
because that's just it's just imaginary
there's fiction
so uh it it mr ripson's here to
represent
all the analysis has been done to date
uh it is so despite my emotional
outburst there mr ripson if you had to
guess the number right now based on all
of your analysis of all this data for
over all of these years and we were
projecting for a facility for the next
20 to 30 years
what what number would you sick select
the number that we the number that we
continue to support is 18. that's not
based on the idea that we expect there
to be 18 kids there but based on the
idea which was written in one of the
very early versions of
of this language i think back during the
budget process is that we anticipate an
average daily census of 12
but that given the need to separate
three different groups two different
groups for male one for female that you
need some excess capacity because you're
not going to have an exact number of
females in the two different groups on
any given day you need some flexibility
in spacing i think that's what the data
to date shows and and to the extent that
the argument is that um there's been a
lot of analysis to point to a lower
number um you know when i first got here
people were talking about building a
facility for 40
right that's only three i've only been
here for
four and a half years at this point um
people were talking about building three
different facilities in the state at 20
a piece i mean there are lots of ideas
being floated around
and the fact that we've gone from about
75 kids when i arrived in this state to
an average of 12 i think is pretty
remarkable progress and when i talk to
my colleagues around the country they're
shocked by that progress
but i haven't seen the evidence yet
that we're at a place where we can
operate with sex and again i point back
to the reality that that dcyf sysc
does not decide who goes to this
facility judges decide that
prosecutors impact that public defenders
impact that
certainly we get asked for
probation officers opinions on these
cases but we're not the deciders we just
have to take all comers no matter what
and until i see data that the people who
decide these things have us down to
operating at six i'd be horribly
uncomfortable with
with operating at that number
thank you so so we've spent uh 32
minutes on on this particular topic and
it's a critical topic because it's like
the number one cost driver of the whole
replacement facility and then it's going
to be the cost driver behind the
staffing behind it and so it's really
important that the committee
pick an approach to this that
works because if we don't pass
this
bill
there's no plan uh the sununu center by
law has to just shut down at the end of
march
uh there there is no continuity of
operations without this bill
it would be irresponsible for is to not
pass this bill
and we can't pass this bill unless we
agree on a number
so what i think i'm going to do is i'm
going to put us into
a recess for five minutes so that we can
discuss this in caucus
okay we're out of uh recess for our
caucuses
and um
what uh we're going to discuss next is
uh
senate bill 458
as passed by the policy committee and as
uh approved by the house
i'll entertain a motion
i'd move we
recommend otp
who seconded
okay
is there any discussion
um when you're ready
mr clerk would you please take a roll
on the motion of ought to pass on senate
bill 458
representative irf yes
representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
representative walner
yeah
representative long yes
representative walls yes
chairman
edwards
no
six to one
so with that uh the motion carries uh
who will write the
blurb uh there will not be a minority
report
okay
okay so we're on
um
sb 459
this ripple is was there was no
amendment prepared for 459 right i don't
think there was there wasn't okay
so uh we have a
discussion draft that's available
um
could you pass that
over and yours is here
sure
we'll wait for mr ripple to return to
hand out copies to the audience
mm-hmm
foreign
okay so we're going to start talking
about uh sb 459
um
i had prepared
a discussion draft i think that's my
copy
um
and uh i i sent this out
last night
you got a copy of it represented walnut
from last night
did you did you see that from last night
okay
all right no i'm just trying to make
sure that i had provided her a digital
copy last night
so um
i think i'd like to walk through this
and then have some discussion
at the appropriate times the
the first thing that uh that i suggest
we do
is the definition of workplace violence
i i think
was so broad it no longer meant
workplace violence it meant something
else
so it included
uh verbal abuse even if the victim
had no stress
so so so that didn't seem to make sense
so
tightened up workplace violence so that
a normal person would understand the
word violence and then created a new
definition
for hostile words hostile words means
aggressive belligerent verbal abuse in
which the recipient reasonably believes
that the speaker intends to injure or
create
excessive stress or in which the
recipient suffers psychological trauma
i'm not wedded to that particular
definition but i am sort of wedded to
the concept of
of breaking workplace violence up
into um a distinct subsect because
initially it's just it's just so broad
it doesn't mean anything any comment on
that
i agree
representative
thank you so
again you know i don't
i'm not on criminal i don't do criminal
work usually but often in the law
specific words have developed specific
meanings their specific definitions are
out there on specific meanings
and i'm trying to understand where this
definition of hostile words came from is
that a
widely accepted definition i said i
invented it
you invented it yeah i believe i said
that
i i wrote that because
uh workplace violence was uh so
inclusive it needed to be broken out so
i i wrote the definition of hostile
words
so the question i have is
has this been through legislative
services
no okay well no the re there's
discussion that's great
there's a reason i'm asking that and
that is
you know i i just want to be careful
when we're inventing definitions in the
law
that we're not changing definitions that
are out there in another part of the law
and inconsistent with it because there
are words that have come to have meaning
and that meaning is across the board in
lots of different crimes or civil
actions
and
when we invent new words i just out of
an interest in time i agree with you and
the purpose of this is to discuss it the
pro and it will need to go through oos
before we have a draft so i think you're
concerned about finding alternative
definitions that are already in the law
we can do that when we run this through
ols as you recall this bill was voted
out on thursday and we have no time to
really do this the justices needs i'd be
open to interim study this bill and then
we could have all kinds of times
i'm i'm not open to interim studying it
because i think it's urgent that we
protect our health care workers but
before we do this i just was looking to
find out if somebody who knows more
about criminal law than i do
could help me understand
if it may be great that you've invented
this all the whole cloth and it may work
just fine right here i'm not saying it
doesn't i'm just saying we need to find
out
how about the where i started though
did do you agree with the way the
workplace violence was defined in the uh
in the bill that we received
workplace violence means any act or
threat of physical violence harassment
intimidation or other threatening
behavior that occurs at a health care
facility including verbal abuse without
regard whether the victim sustains an
injury psychological trauma or stress
if a victim has no stress from words is
that workplace violence
what jumps at me with my legal mind is
some of these things require something
called men's rhea which in english it
means intent and was this
language an attempt to
address a need for intent i don't know
the answer to this but i look at this
with different eyes than you do
because of my training and it just
raises questions for me and i'm not
trying to be critical of what you did
i think words are there for a reason and
having gotten this the last minute i
don't know
if by taking those words out we're
taking out an element that has
unintended consequences that's all i'm
trying to say i'm not saying i agree or
disagree with them i'm just saying
without knowing the history of how that
definition got there and what the intent
was of what what's the waterfront they
were trying to cover with those words
i'm reluctant to change it without
having more information that's all
thank you
is there any other comment on the
definitional part
all right i think it leaves it so broad
that if a nurse walks into a room and
the person turns their back on them and
ignores them
some might say that's a hostile act so
you know it just it is wide open
for what it's worth i agree with your
definitions
thank you
um so then in two i'm just looking at it
trying to figure out what i what i did
here i created a new
paragraph 4 and that caused some
remembering
said
health facilities
may implement and maintain a workplace
violence prevention program
so this gets right at the issue of
of the financial impact of this policy
is that this has been set up to be
mandatory where the straight state is
directing that these programs take place
and we saw that when it just looked at
our two hospitals without
regard to the third that will be opening
uh if everything goes well
um
it
it adds an fte per facility in order to
run these internal programs
so uh so what what i did here
was basically say that participation
in
an
internal workplace violence program
having one
is a
is not mandated by this program but it
is encouraged
said program may consider the size and
complexity of the health facility and
shall address
the following topics or others deemed
appropriate by the health facility the
goal of which is to encourage
participation
and address prevention recognition
response and reporting of workplace
violence
so it maintains the program
by including
the elements that would have been in the
program but rather than making them
mandatory it makes them suggestive and
it also opens it up so
that it it it can be more the program
could be more than what was described
is there any comment about just strictly
limiting for a second the conversation
on
voluntary or versus mandatory
requirements to have an internal
workplace violence program
and before anyone talks i care deeply
about violence in a healthcare workplace
i've worked 43 years in hospitals i've
seen it
and
i i think health care administrators
want to preclude this anyways
go ahead representative walls
i think changing your first shale to
make guts the program i think it makes
it meaningless and it eliminates the
protections that this bill is trying to
provide to our health care workers i
think some of the other maze that you've
done i mean i kind of went through as
much of this as i could read in the time
allotted because i didn't see it until
right now
some of the mays are
acceptable but that one in particular i
think that just guts it and i think if
we don't require a facility to have a
workplace prevention program we might as
well not even be passing this because
they can do this without us so saying
may that already exists what we're
trying to do here is provide the
protection and the way we're going to
provide the protection is to say shell
is there any other comment on that
the nurses lobbyist called me to say
that they felt
that it wasn't required it wouldn't be
done but i see you have language in here
to require a report so if they don't
bring in the program they have to report
why which may put pressure on them to
bring in the program especially if you
create a lengthy thing to describe why
don't you have such a program and what
is your experience if you put that in
there to to try to explain it force them
to makes a decision i think
so the totality of it was meant to
create
a bottoms up
free market of criticism and pressure
instead of a top-down
directive mandate
from a government
and so in a live free or die state when
i heard so much about how everyone wants
to do this and everyone cares
it doesn't seem to me like a mandate is
necessary what is needed is guidance and
leadership
and and that's what
i attempted to do with this rewrite
uh representative irf
thank you mr chair so i agree
that it doesn't seem
like a mandate is necessary however one
of the things that we heard the other
day
had something to do with the legal
gymnastics of it and and i can't speak
to that directly i'm sure there's
somebody here who can but i did speak
probably with the same lobbyist that
representative wallner spoke to
regarding how we could get
i think all the way to what you want but
without removing the word mandate
so in the course of that conversation
i asked so is everybody are all the
hospitals on board and i believe the
answer we got to that last
uh yesterday last week last week
was yes
okay i said how about all the urgent
care centers
no the two biggest ones are
and the three that are less have fewer
than three clinics i don't know if
they're not or they're or they're they
haven't responded but in any case uh the
suggestion was made to
as is already in the bill later on
relating to the members of the
commission uh the members for the health
the urgent cares as i recall come from
the those with larger than three clin
with more than three clinics the
suggestion was made to put that same
wording up into the definition of
healthcare facility and in fact i guess
i can probably read you the language
better if you want to hear the actual
language
so
health facility
as it's currently stated with another
sentence the term does not include any
non-hospital
urgent care with less than three clinics
in new hampshire so with that my
understanding is there's nobody that
would be affected by this that doesn't
want to be affected by it except for the
state perhaps i'll come back to that
so that gets rid of the yes it's still
mandatory but
but everybody wants to be in
give one second i'll get back to where i
was i've heard that but i've actually
not seen any documentation to show each
facility has said that they want to be
in this i've heard it said but i've not
seen it
i'll let others speak to that let me let
me go through the things i think we need
to change and then you can have people
up to speak to that i obviously i can't
speak to that myself and personally
go ahead okay um so as you have
suggested we need to remove all
personally identifiable identifiable
information i mean there's any
disagreement from the reports that are
produced i don't think there's any
disagreement about that
strike the two thousand dollar fine and
by that essentially you're making it
voluntary because if anybody
doesn't get involved
they're not going to get fined what's
going to happen so you're so that gives
you back to your goal if nobody has to
be in there they want to be in there
include your definitions of workplace
violence and hostile words and then of
course get hostile words into the proper
places in the document and i have one
sample cut at that which i was going to
send to mr ripple later
today maintain your repeal date um i
think it was in 10 years or something so
so keep that let whatever it is
so that the program can be looked at as
you suggest in that time frame and see
if it still needs to be
in place
and if we all feel it's appropriate
remove state facilities they apparently
have very good programs already and that
would eliminate the cost and they they
could be optionally invited to attend so
would you do that in a as you're
redefining the definition of health
facility
i mean where would that happen yeah sure
i mean you're you're talking about how
you would limit the size of the urgent
care centers and we could uh in that
definition actually exclude state yeah
yes and i actually asked uh kevin again
i asked mitch ripple about this he did
this didn't have time to do it today but
the idea would be to not only include
nhh and and uh
glencliff home obviously also hamsa will
be coming on board but it should be
general enough that any future state
facility doesn't have to be involved and
appropriate wording to let them opt in
so i think that's all of the items that
would turn it into something closer to
what you're looking for without the word
mandate and if i missed anything perhaps
the other folks that speak to it but i
think you could speak to the people here
that could give you some confidence
about the
the people that
really want to be into the in this and
why they want to be in it thank you mr
chair
so i added into this references to
uh rsa 354a right to freedom from
discrimination in public workplaces
because i
i think that
helps clarify
the expectations of behavior towards one
another
do you have an issue with that
no sir
would you
if we recast this more along the lines
that you're suggesting would you keep uh
the part here
on the second page where
it says
health facilities opting out of
participation with the new hampshire
health care workplace safety commission
shall submit a written notification
within 15 days of the effective date of
the legislation
stating their decision to opt out
would you keep that
sure i mean are you basically saying if
any of the facilities um
that
just wanted to jump out without being
fined
you want this out of them from them is
that what you're saying
i don't know does it become um
superfluous to have them sign a document
opting out if
if your observation is correct and it
basically becomes voluntary without any
fines anyways i i guess i will leave it
to the rest of the committed i mean i
have no problem with that being in there
leave it to the rest of the committee
determined if that's
representing weiler do you have an uh an
opinion
we're talking about this
having their submit something in writing
then they can't deny that it's been
offered and then their employees can say
why did can look at what they offered
and say why
make you make them explain
are there any other comments on this
point
representative walsh just can you tell
me i'm not exactly sure which paragraph
you're talking about
it's it's a little hard because this
isn't numbered it turns out to be the
second page if you flip it over and if
you go down about 60 percent it says
renumber from here before
healthcare facilities opting out of
participation that that section
basic basically i'm saying you know if a
hospital or or one of these covered
entities don't want to participate they
would be expected to
say so in writing
that is meant to bring public pressure
on them
so that
they would have a bottoms-up approach
to
wanting to participate
without the state coercing it
so
today when there's a shortage of health
care workers out there
i agree health care workers are going to
be inclined to look at something like
this and go maybe this is not where i
want to work but we're educating
healthcare workers like crazy and maybe
in five or ten years we're going to have
a lot of health care workers and i
would like to just
i don't have a problem with mandating
this i think we need to protect workers
period
and um
i think there are always going to be
people willing to work at those
facilities that don't have the safety
provisions in place and then they're
going to be victimized they're they're
going to get hurt somebody's going to
hurt them i think we should be mandating
that's just my belief i just think so
should we extend the mandate to home
depot
do you care equally about uh all workers
or are we just doing a carve out for
health care and treating them as a
separate part of society
i think there's social and other things
that address home depot i'm just talking
about right now health care workers
and i'd be interested in hearing what
representative earth is trying to say
my comments were related to the existing
bill so there would be a mandate
the modifications i was talking about
were to the existing bill
not to not to represent ezra's bills and
that what he was asking was of the items
that are in his
proposal would we keep
for instance education rsa
354-a colon 29
etc and would we keep the health
facilities so the idea is that we would
stick with the mandate that was that was
everything i was describing
when my conversations with the with the
lobbyists that they were willing to
basically
change those things and there was
essentially a voluntary mandatory system
i can't remember what the words were
they they used was actually something
like
like that
if we have mass speak i don't want to be
unrecognized okay thank you i didn't
need to jump the gun um
so the idea is to have it be
mandatory for pry facility private
facilities but voluntary for state
facilities is that my understanding well
the suggestion was again this came from
the lobbyists if we're concerned about
the cost the only cost in the bill is
the state facility saying they have to
have people
so
my understanding is the state has a
pretty good it has pretty good programs
in place so if we the committee decide
to eliminate the cost all we have to do
is say the states don't have the state
facilities don't have to be part of the
mandatory
uh they can be an exception to the
mandatory demand
so i'm wondering matt
mattha
may i follow up yes so what about if we
say state facilities run by the state
but if the state facilities are run by a
private entity then they're subject to
this
so that if we're talking about state
employees that's exempt but if the state
has contracted out the running one of
these facilities to a private entity
what would you think about then making
it mandatory for them
i don't want any of this mandatory so
i'm i'm all i'm already being drugged
through the razor wire okay uh
this this this is not why i got shot at
is to tell hospitals that they have to
do a program that is common sense that
they ought to do
but
mr chairman i cannot get over the fact
of the story that i was told as i told
you two weeks ago about two
strangulations at dartmouth-hitchcock
two not one but two and they still don't
have the the safety precautions in place
to ensure that doesn't happen i mean
these are serious things that are
happening in what's probably the best
hospital in the state and they
should have the money and they should
have the motivation to protect their
workers and they're not
let me for the record state that i'm
opposed to strangulation of anyone
uh i and i think that an institution as
wealthy and as enlightened as dartmouth
would be all over this that they don't
need the state to do this to them right
but but they're not maybe maybe i'm
naive i just think better of people um
all right so
uh let's let's
just just to point out what
representative erf has suggested and
which has changed things is where on the
first page in section two
where it reads where i deleted the word
shall and inserted may
earth
would like to keep shall
and get rid of may so the shall would
remain and so what we were trying to do
is crosswalk the rest of this
to see if there are any good components
that we ought to keep in the division
three amendment
i'm sorry i'm a little thick and i know
you just said this but i want to hear it
clearly so we're looking at line
and the shell there you're suggesting
that
on page 1 line 12 on the original bill
wait i don't have that in front of me
okay
let me explain to you what he's doing
yeah because i'm getting a little lost
maybe we should start with
did everybody understand what i was
doing that i was starting from the
original bill and making those half a
dozen changes to try to make it more of
a quote voluntary system with a
mandatory word do we get that
okay so if you all are on board with
that hopefully
so that's our basis we're starting from
that point what representative edwards
is doing is going through his amendment
and suggesting pieces of his amendment
that
would they also be appropriate to be
incorporated into
the bill as it is
thank you does that make sense yeah i'm
just i'm sorry i was having a hard time
following
thank you that does help keith thank you
very
much go ahead you're on a roll
i don't know what other pieces you want
to add in i can add i can discuss those
two that we talked about you might go
through those two or do you want to sure
let's just wrap up the two okay so he
mentioned
two right off the bat on the second page
one of the ones you wanted to keep on
the second page is the first thing
that's well the second thing that's
heavily bolded it's about eight lines
down it has a number two and parens in
front of it it relates to freedom from
discrimination
and i don't personally see a problem
with including that in the in the bill
but if others do they can
suggest that they do
further down on that same page where
that's what he mentioned earlier the
renumber from here and for that that
paragraph
he would also like to uh include in the
um
in the original bill
i'll let you
yeah and and i also want to charge the
commissioner of dhhs on staying on top
of the
eligible members once we get the health
care facility definition uh hammered out
and
have the commissioner know who's
actively in the program and and if
people are not or institutions are not
actively involved
that they would be
indicated as not being active
uh later i suggest in the bill that
they create a website where all this
stuff is very transparent
so that there's an opportunity for the
public to know who's participating and
who is not and therefore they can put
their own bottoms up pressure on the
system
comment
well
i find it very confusing
to
on
one hand say
that they may implement now that they
keep in shall they shall implement and
then come over here and have opt out
i mean maybe there's a different way of
saying if
a healthcare facility is not
does not
abide by this
they have to do a report but it then
opens up for me oh well maybe i can out
there yeah so i agree with your point uh
once it when we went from
may to shall
this shifted this paragraph
so i i would just see deleting most of
the paragraph but what i would like to
see remain
is the commissioner of the dhhs shall
follow up so their participants status
is at proactively known
such the
participation status is properly
reported in the annual report
so so if there is somebody who's covered
who's supposed to be covered by a show
but isn't coming to any meetings
the commissioner would annotate that in
the annual report that
xyz hospital is supposed to be in the
program but never came to a meeting
never provided a report that that's what
i'm trying to do there
so you would take out the opt out i'd
take the opt out out because it just
doesn't make any sense
once it becomes
mandatory
okay
mr ripple
have i lost you because because i i
could try harder no
i get it so that last sentence under
renumber from here most of it would be
out but the sentence that begins the
commissioner of hhs that would stay in
and
you know we might have to
figure out where exactly in the in the
rsa it would go but it would be in there
somewhere
okay good thank you
okay so then the next one does another
xiaomi
each
health facility
may prepare
and submit to the healthcare workplace
safety commission an annual report
so in talking to
one of the lobbyists
it was suggested to me
that
the report
probably ought to be mandatory even if
we made
the
development of an internal program
optional
and so if we were to honor that feedback
this should just not be changed at all
it should just remain
with the shells
moving on the chair of the joint hhs
oversight committee with the advice of
the commission may recommend updates to
new hampshire statutes sort of the rule
making process led by jail car
basically what what was going on prior
to this
is that the commission was going direct
to the com
excuse me the commission
the workplace violence commission was
going to the commissioner of dhhs
directly
in saying
that the commissioner of dhhs
was supposed to
promulgate rules
uh with the advice and consent of the
members of the commission and i i don't
i don't think we want to delegate
the uh executive branch action
based on the consent of a commission
i i i think a smart commissioner would
listen to the commission and and
interpret
it but
the consent of the commission for the
commissioner to act
should not be part of this
is there any comment on that
okay and so so how about the inclusion
of the joint
hhs oversight committee as as part of
this process
i think it's a good place to land a
report on workplace violence
and if there are laws that are needed
it's the right place for people to
consider whether or not there are new
laws needed
i see you nodding
it's good
okay
all right so on the next page the third
page i got into playing around when the
annual report would be due
and and this is just me sitting alone so
if you have a different opinion share it
but i can tell you my reasoning at the
time i thought having the annual report
done at the end of december
would be good because by the time
um
the budget process started we'd have a
current fresh copy of a report and so if
there are any budget items
it could be
addressed uh in the normal order
but i don't really have a strong opinion
other than i do think that we should be
more clear on when the annual report is
due
mr chairman
so
is this the annual report for each
facility or just one annual report from
the commissioner i i believe in this
reference this is meant to be the
commission on workplace violence their
annual report and they would have to
aggregate data from
multiple institutions in order to do a
roll-up
which is why i think i gave them some
time to actually complete the report
so let me suggest if the where you have
changed shell to may there in the second
line
that if you do that what i'm afraid of
is that there will not be
standardization among facilities
so i i'll give up on the shell we can it
can be a shot i just think
i i i don't believe that it
standardization wouldn't work
without it but i'm okay okay so let's
change that back to shell if you don't
mind except representing your verb has
got an idea i can see okay okay
go ahead representation i just want to
point out that this is not the end
report
this is one that's produced by each of
the healthcare facilities number four
which is what this references back to
says each health facility shall prepare
and submit to the healthcare workplace
safety blah blah blah so this is talking
about what that annual report is and i
don't disagree that it shouldn't be a
date certain you might want to actually
say that for the calendar year ending
december 31st must be prepared by
january 15th or january 30th or
something so you have the whole full
year to work with four years worth of
data and then the report comes out in
january
just a thought
you know i don't see it but i i recall
somewhere that i did set a date for when
the report was supposed to be due
elsewhere but i but i may be wrong i was
getting punched happy yesterday
so um okay so the next item
the incident including environmental and
patient-specific risk factors present at
the time of the incident and then i
added as well as the appropriate
categorization of the incident as
workplace violence and or hostile words
the reason i inserted that is because i
want these reports to be meaningful
and i don't want to have a definition
where we're aggregating data into a
category so large that there's no way to
really interpret the data so i'm
suggesting that there should be
categorization and clarity
any comment on that any opposition
okay
next next down we're talking about
classifications
um
i
i i
i inserted but not any identifiable
personal information
because up above it had included the
possibility of or actually the
requirement that the names and job
titles of employees involved in the
incident i i want this stripped of
personal data
and about the only exception i would uh
include would be if there's a police
report that gets attached because a
police report is you know public
information
and then i left somewhere in here i
talked about other governmental entity
official documents
you know in case i overlook something
with the police report
is there any comment about
making sure these reports are
devoid of personal data
no
uh mr chairman i just
i agree with everything you're saying
except i don't see in here where police
reports are included that's all
i i i i'm hoping to portend a future
event because i i do believe
it's in here somewhere but we'll we'll
see
um okay so i'm dropping down the little
g
um
so the percentage of employees that have
participated in the workplace violence
program
okay so this was left ambiguous so
somebody could interpret it and say
every time i'm to include a percentage
of employees i need to calculate the
most recent 12 months
and rather than having to do a constant
recalculation every time they're looking
at this i'm saying that they should uh
use the the
the
kind of a fixed percentage for
their participation in the training and
the like
in the prior year
do you have a comment on that
representative walner
no
okay
how about you sean
are you do you have a copy of this are
you tracking any of this
okay
so this is just clarity and and and
having to share
the data instead of having to
recalculate the data all the time i'm
saying just use a point in time from the
report
well come on to the mic because you're
you're on youtube you're gonna be famous
thank you very much mr chair sean thomas
from demers and praise representing the
new hampshire nurses association
so with respect to this
to g
the idea here is this number would only
be calculated once and be included in
this annual report from the facility to
the commission
and so would be
the percentage with respect to the
entire year
so you know if 95 of employees say had
completed this training the number then
would be 95 percent
it wouldn't it's not per incident it
doesn't need to be recalculated each
incident it's just per report which is
once per year okay and that may not be
clear i think i think i tried to write
it that way if anyone doesn't think
that's written well that that the mr
thomas just explained what i was trying
to get at
go ahead representative i think what
he's saying is remember recall this is
an annual report so it's only being done
once
i know but what what
they also were talking about incidences
and that
every time and you can have an inci you
could have 12 incidences once a month
and so this was just to just clarify
that when there's an incident
you're not having to calculate the
percentage of the prior 12 months you're
supposed to go use the
yeah that's that's what i was trying to
do
uh mr or representative weiler yes sir
i predicted a minority of the people
eligible to file reports
will file the majority of the reports
and it be no way from this
way this is written to tell
that that was the case right is that a
good thing or a bad thing well
i think as an employer you'd want to
know if there's some that have very
thin-skinned and see everything as an
attack while others are
more tolerant
i see what your point is
uh
but because we have a non-retaliation
clause in this later it may make it
better for the employer to not know
from these reports who's
creating the incident reports you know
the lack of knowledge could be a defense
if somebody claims retaliation but
it's just a thought that's brainstorming
um
i the participation status of each
health care facility eligible for active
cooperation in this workplace
program so this i think that's referring
to the annual report
you know just a clear delineation by
hospital name who is involved who's
supposed to be in this program and who's
actively participating
um
again the thought was a free market
pressure campaign could be launched if
somebody's not participating
there
jay there shall not be any identifiable
personal personal information recorded
in any report here it is representative
walls
unless contained within an attached
police report or other official report
of a governmental entity violations may
be adjudicated under the provisions of
the right to freedom of discrimination
in the workplace i think that's the
correct reference
um but because i think it representative
or mr ripple
that that's something you may want to
highlight for uh ols i i think that's
the right adjudication for
but i could be wrong
the next one uh seven roman numeral
seven all persons within a health care
facility are protected by the right to
freedom of discrimination and public
workplaces in education that's a true
statement it's just adding clarity to
the rest of it
um no person or health care facility
shall retaliate in any manner against
any reporting individual acting in good
faith
mr thomas was earlier willing to accept
the addition of the concept of good
faith
so that an employee
couldn't kind of weaponize
this reporting system
uh just to you know create havoc
so
so this this just says as long as
they're working in good faith they
they're protected
any issue there
okay
dropping down
the commissioner the department of
health and human services shall be
responsible for maintaining an easily
navigable searchable distinct page on
the department's website to share
information on the activities of the new
hampshire healthcare workplace safety
commission
topics to be included on the page shall
include but not be limited to and then a
bunch of things but first is just the
idea that this is an addition to the
existing bill that we had
because i'm trying to create public
pressure to participate and not just
you know
a government
mandate
any issues with that do you want this on
the websites or not
why not i hear
so what would they put on there they
would put a listing of all health care
facilities by names with their business
address included which are
subject to the provisions of this
program that we're writing
they would include the participation
status of each facility as active
opted out which no longer makes sense
or unknown
uh i i i don't know
opted out probably should be replaced
with something like inactive maybe
if they're since we're getting rid of
the opt out
do you see that mr ripple that too
where it says opted out
very bottom of the page
very bottom of the page last night yes
okay i see opted out just make that
inactive
change to inactive got it and if anyone
has a better way of categorizing
participation i'm i'm open that's just
can i say something what made sense
yesterday uh representative irf and miss
ripple note that the old section 7 got
deleted that was the one that contained
the fine information that that's where
it's getting dropped out okay
yeah that's coming up here in a moment
um the meeting date the other thing that
they'll report on the website is the
meeting dates of each meeting of the new
hampshire health care workplace safety
commission
i i wouldn't mind if these were
retroactive dates when the commission's
met
i don't know that they need to be
perspective because later in the
confidentiality part i don't think we're
making this uh
a public meeting so
so posting dates in advance aren't is
aren't necessary
uh i would want them to hyperlink access
to each approved set of new hampshire
healthcare workplace safety commission
minutes
if minutes of the meeting are not
available the meeting date will be
listed with the statement minutes
unavailable so this raised a
conversation
about
if this is uh if these meetings are
confidential confidential what would
these minutes be doing
i i think you could still write
high-level minutes to inform the public
of what's going on
by saying here the here's the date we
met
here are the organizations that were
present here are the organizations that
were absent we talked about these issues
and these are some of the things that we
think should be considered by the
commission in the future or
by the state with new law
so i think they can do high level
minutes without violating the
confidentiality we're giving them
any comment on that
okay
so annually for the year ending in the
calendar year a press release shall be
issued within 60 days highlighting the
act of participation in health care
facilities and any major findings or
recommendations
in the army they used to call these
attaboys
an opportunity to publicly acknowledge
participation and give thanks
i think i think they could be good press
releases and again it's a source of
public pressure
any issue with including that
okay so i removed
all the next which had been in there
allowing
discretion to the commissioner to of
dhhs to issue two thousand dollar fines
comments on
removing the fines
mr thomas do you have a comment on
removing the fine
representative we're okay with removing
the fines if that means uh the program
remains mandatory
so so far have you heard anything that
make you think that we're
not going to make this mandatory and i i
don't mean all the 42 conversations i i
mean the public hearing today no sir all
right
okay thank you
you may as well sit there if you'd
um
now that i can trust what you have to
say
representative edwards
yes representative walner well we've got
mr thomas up here go ahead are there any
other pieces that we've just gone
through
particularly i was wondering about all
this
policy for the department of health and
human services and
it on the website and all of that is
there any parts of that that are
concerning or are you
set with that
uh
obviously i think primarily that's an
issue for the department i mean what i
would say specifically about that piece
uh and representative edwards already
commented on this
uh i think specifically we were
concerned with the meeting dates being
included uh with these meetings being
confidential and not public and why that
would be necessary uh and then why the
minutes would be included presumably the
minutes two would be confidential but
you know he he
based on how he describes it i don't
think those are those seem to be
non-issues at this point it's it's a
question that question now whether or
not the department that's okay with the
department and that's not for
for us to worry about but we're okay
with it with that piece being in there
ms minahan did you have to an opinion
offer i'm sorry i'll let you continue
sorry and i'm sorry i had to step out
i'm starting i was running a zoom and
down the hall
so
i
i did talk with
the
individual that runs our quality program
at the
foundation for healthy communities and
she's staff for the quality commission
and she is very concerned about all of
that being put on the website
and because the entire process
of the quality commission which this
commission is mirrored after
and
we worked really carefully to mirror it
we none of that should be
all of that is confidential and it
should not be on the department's
website
there will be no public
minutes
i'm not
i'm not quite understanding where that
came from and i apologize i didn't not
hear that discussion point um
representative edward so so i can tell
you where it came from i i i invented it
because what i was attempting to do
was to create
a public awareness component of this
uh
commission
so that staff
patients community members
could be informed of what's going on and
that they could uh
apply their own form of pressure to
encourage
uh the participation of the
uh entity
so so uh
so i i'm i'm okay with striking d on the
minutes
because that was just an idea to you
know
if you want if you want the public to
move you got to give them some
information so this was my thought that
the commission could decide
what it may want to include in the
minutes
to demonstrate that they're
a useful organization and that people
should care about them
it was a marketing piece
thank you for that clarification um
there is an annual report um
as like with the quality commission um
so i don't believe that that is
necessary i also am concerned about
adding the freedom from discrimination
in public workplace references
my understanding from reviewing that rsa
is that is for um
that does not apply to private entities
so i don't and the hospitals already are
um
follow federal
anti-discrimination um so i don't i
don't believe that that is actually
necessary i think that's a
misinterpretation though
rsa 354 is
covers the state and it includes private
entities okay that's not that was not my
reading i i cannot support putting that
in there um i
our position is the commission as
drafted um we were we were supportive of
because again
we worked really hard
on that entire drafting
i also wasn't clear why the annual
report was being moved to the end of the
year and i again i'm sorry i had to step
out of the room i had to explain that
because um i wanted the report done
freshly enough so it could be considered
in the budget process
i'm trying to make it relevant
um and again we we support mandatory um
we don't support um voluntary
and i think we're gonna look do you
understand that we're working so
we're working from your original bill
and we're taking pieces of this and
putting it in the original bill so it is
still mandatory okay minus defines and
okay some some of the some institutions
the the small urgent care facilities
yeah you're here for that part of the
conversation yes okay yeah i don't have
an opinion on the urgent care centers um
so i i appreciate um that if
to take them out
they
they may or may not want to participate
i'm not sure um the hospital urgent care
centers will but
okay thank you were there any other
questions representative
i had a question about the
[Music]
the calendar date of december 31st
you
so you didn't feel that was an
appropriate date
or
was it necessary well the effective date
is starts in july of 23 so i thought we
were going to be following that that
fiscal state fiscal year um
that's that's why i thought i wasn't
understanding why it was going to to
december
i don't know that that's necessarily
problematic except
if it starts in july i was thinking do
we have a short first year of six months
report
or do we have an 18 month that's why i
was getting confused about that i didn't
understand i'd say yes and it's probably
going to take you six months to get all
the carbon blown out of the cylinders to
get the reporting going
okay any other questions
okay so
uh
the next one down
you know i have no
uh
i don't really care about it i i the
members of the commission may ideally be
composed instead of shao and i
uh i just i i just like if this is going
to be a private entity
that they have the flexibility to do a
little self-government and if they
had different members
then
it's really not a state issue
but so i could see
mr ripple just keeping that as a shall
then on duties down below
the duty of the commission shall propose
changes
and this just changes who they're uh
plugging into
proposed changes to the joint
legislative health and human services
committee and the commissioner of dhhs
so because the so that there's a direct
legit legislative communication
is there any issue there
i'm not seeing any
the next one on the next page d probably
should just be stricken since we don't
we no longer have uh envisioned the
possibility of an opt out
on
uh on the chair when they get elected
uh
my suggestion was to have the very
initial term of the chair be for three
years instead of two years
so that you get into a method where
you're always overlapping an experienced
vice chair with a brand new chair an
experienced chair with a brand new vice
chair so it's kind of a one-time deal
to to have the chair serve for three
years and not two but subsequently two
that's what that's intended to do
any concerns
anyone thinking that's a brilliant idea
yeah yes yes that's brilliant thank you
we're going to take that in testimony
okay so
but seriously if anyone doesn't like
that let me know
um
then in
education
the chair will be respond this is an
addition the chair will be responsible
for ensuring information intended for
the public
is transmitted in appropriate format to
the commissioner of dhhs or designee
and again the belief is that we want
the public aware enough of what's going
on so that the staff and the public
can let the hospital systems know that
they care about workplace violence
and and that i deleted and i have to
think why but i deleted all such
information shall be demons
disseminated
through each participant's safety and
security program well i i don't know
that if you if we're saying each
participant is supposed to have a safety
security program or are we already
getting too much into the internal
affairs of and and operational structure
of the
members i it just seems like that was
too specific your comment there mr
thomas
what i would say to that is is that
particular language is
comes exactly out of the
uh quality safety commission after which
this commission is modeled so this is
already existing language and current
law
it's a process that is known and that
protects the confidentiality which is
obviously of utmost importance in this
case
and then with respect to the piece you
added the sentence you added above i
would only just want to reference in
down in section 7 151 j7
i think this is already addressed
where it says specifically
any information about processes or
outcomes provided pursuant to this
section shall be aggregate data only and
shall not reference individual incidents
patients health care providers or
institutions so i don't know that it's
necessary in this particular location as
well
well the this is sort of got the
opposite intent though this this is
meant to have the chair
use the dhhs website
as a way of being a beacon to the public
about the program this this this is this
is the opposite of confidentiality this
is the chair
deciding
how to use the website process to get
appropriate attention on this program
just
so so just to get it out of here
the strikethrough from all such
information through disgust i could see
just putting it back in there then
but do you do you still have a concern
about the addition of the
the the public transmission
um as i state
i we do the hospital association again
that is not the intent of the commission
that's not how the quality commission is
structured there is an annual report as
stated and that is how um
this information is disseminated so we
we are not um
i'm not quite sure how that all would
work but um
we respectfully um
believe that
the reporting the annual reporting um
accomplishes the same thing
right
is the whole annual report public
[Music]
yes
so i thought this was such an important
topic with incidences like two
strangulations happening every month
you know that that that there was more
contemporaneous need for information
sharing and public awareness
this this this was an attempt to help
highlight the importance of this
commission you want to underplay that
um i
am
following
representative edwards all the work of
the study committee and the experts that
testified and this is the approach that
was agreed upon as i shared with you on
senate bill 100
study committee report
so
again
the quality commission has had 17 years
of success and
that structure is what we uh
respectfully want to follow um so
i'm i'm not sure
mr ripple uh just keep 151 j4 education
the same no changes
no changes to
your proposal no to the way the bill
came over okay
um and then in confidentiality all
information other than public facing
minutes or police reports
and then it goes on
so it does allow that there may be a
police report
that could be included if necessary
do you have a problem with that
i would need to check with um folks i'll
need to check on that
uh so down on three
uh in addition um
uh this is about the
incidents where individuals are involved
nevertheless the principles of data
minimization will be respected to
include de-identification of any
personally identifiable information
so far we've said that that's
the intent anyway so
uh and the under administration uh added
the phrase and data privacy to make the
sentence the final sentence on the page
read the activities of the department of
health and human services and its
employees or agents shall be subject to
the same confidentiality provisions and
data privacy as those that apply to the
commission
going on to the last page uh that's just
an issue again with the
when is the report due
the go ahead
you might want to move that into january
so they can capture all of the year's
data
is this the annual report you're talking
about yeah i don't i like i said i just
uh threw a dart at that and my goal in
the big picture was just to have a fresh
report for the budget process so maybe
that report is coming out
you know january
31.
can you change that january 31 as of
december 31st
okay
um
then the such report
may describe the activities of the
commission
and i wanted to be able to say
that we would indicate the institution's
participation or their lack of
participation if they weren't
participating
so um so let's change that may
there in the middle of that paragraph
to shall
i'd like to keep the lack of
participation
listed as well
you have a problem with highlighting
institutions
that don't participate who are supposed
to
i mean that's the point of making this
mandatory right
right so i don't know that it's
necessary okay
so then at the bottom of that paragraph
uh any information about processes or
outcomes provided pursuant to this
section shall be aggregate data only
shall not reference individual incidents
and then it closes with other than to
identify the health care facilities oh
drop that
that whole black part there can be
deleted it's no longer necessary
on rulemaking i deleted the phrase and
consent of a majority of the members
because the executive branch of the
state government doesn't rely on the
consent of a commission it establishes
so
a smart commissioner will listen to the
advice and then do the right thing
you have an issue with that
does anyone have an issue with those
things
so so so i i think we've gone through
this
mr ripple i think we've given you
enough comments for an amendment to this
uh oh good point nice catch there's one
last one
on the effective date uh i said it shall
be repealed march 1st
2024 34 excuse me 34.
um and that's just that'll give it 10
years and people can relook it
somewhere along the line
representative walner
i just wondered if we had did we come to
a decision around
taking out state facilities or was that
left
i i think we came to that
i assumed we came to that decision but
we can come back and clarify it i i in
order
the whole reason finance is looking at
it is because it's costing fte per
hospital for the state and i just assume
have the state voluntarily participate
without
it becoming mandatory for the state
it doesn't say the state can't
participate
i just wanted to know whether we had how
we had come down on that one so i we i i
think we said that the state could be
excluded from the health facilities but
what is your opinion
well i hope that they will volunteer i
do i mean i think that we could
take them out
at this point i mean basically we're
talking about
i don't even know if glencliff really
qualifies because it's a nursing home
and i'm not sure that nursing homes are
covered here are they let's ask the lba
rep
because this came from lba language
right they're not
nursing homes are not part of this bill
you're correct representative walner i'm
not sure um
glenn cliff is a long-term care facility
so you're right i i don't know how that
got in there honestly i had nothing to
do with the fiscal note okay
mr chairman
i had asked mr ripple for an answer so
let's just give him a chance to respond
i think you're right i think glencliff
and new hampshire hospital this bill
likely would not apply to them even as
written that information was suggested
to me today so the fiscal note may have
been an error in that respect uh going
back to the beginning
and hampstead also wouldn't probably
uh
be required to uh i'm not sure i haven't
had any conversations about that one
you think it makes sense to
leave some wording there that lets it be
well it was new hampshire hospital new
hampshire hospital would have qualified
right
new hampshire hospital would have been
in the definition
it depends on how they are licensed if
they fall under 151 or not
but to like you said to um they have a
probably the most robust program
already
and hospitals have utilized their
training programs they're it's called
what's it called pam knows what it's
called i'm secure it's an acronym
so they have had a program for a long
time and they do report on all sorts of
um incidences so um i don't obviously
speak for new hampshire hospital but um
they
i i again i miss the conversation are
you
contemplating putting it in as an
optional is that what you're thinking
state facilities optional just make it
and then hampstead could be
takes the state cost out
okay
okay mr chairman
uh
representative walls thank you
um i'm wondering if we can add a
provision in there that if a state
facility is run by a private corporation
that they're then subject to this
in other words if they contract
hampstead out do we have one now
no but they're talking there's there's
before the executive council
can we deal with that when it's real
it is real i'm telling you that they're
talking about doing it within the next
month to make hampstead run by a private
facility it's very real right now
do we know how they'd be licensed
would they be licensed according to the
ms minihan doesn't know i don't know
i i'm afraid i don't know i would just
point out they're probably whether i
would qualify they're not run by a
private facility the ceo the cefo all
those folks they're new hampshire dhhs
employees it's below that the con that
the contract picks up so i imagine they
would still qualify as a state facility
that's true the leadership i had not
seen the contract but i was informed of
it today and that raised the concern for
me that
this is
we're going to wait on an amendment
because i think we changed enough stuff
that we just need to see it
mr chairman and then i would like to get
to 275 and i'd like to finish 275 today
because it's the only day it's on our
agenda is your question
important in this moment it is it's i
have one more question
in the version of this bill that we are
turning out is your definition of
hostile words still included
okay is my definition of what hostile
words and representatives said yes well
to that end well that's he answered for
me but but my answer is it's included in
the draft that's going to go to ols and
they can look at the language and if
they think there's some smart lawyer way
to describe the distinction between
workplace violence and hostile words i
i'm open to the smart lawyers
well let me just say i was doing a
little googling when we were here and uh
let me suggest the smart lawyers look at
the definition of harassment and
criminal threatening because i think
it's similar particularly harassment to
what you're trying to do and i just want
to make sure we're not creating
definitions that conflict with those
definitions that are currently in the
rsas that's all i was going to suggest i
agreed
uh representative irf did you have a
question i was just a suggestion asked
ripple about 275 because i believe he
indicated that since you recessed it you
could pick it up again tomorrow
that is true and also um
your revised amendment to 275 is
currently in the works at ols so i think
that probably won't be ready until
tomorrow anyway
we can talk about 275 tomorrow
and we're not violating any paul smith
rules
i don't believe so all right mr edwards
could i
i see john williams is here in the room
yes and also uh representative leon the
vice chair of
uh hhs who who did uh 459. so would you
like to hear from mr williams or do you
want to ask him a question there's just
one specific area i wanted to hear from
come on up there wasn't anyone in the
room when we got down to
on page two of your or page three of
your amendment
when we got down to
a discussion draft
when you we got down to roman numeral
eight the commissioner of health and
human services shall be responsible
for
basically maintaining a website
and we didn't have anybody here from
health and human services to talk to us
about whether that was because this is
all new
whether that was possible impossible
would add cost i mean what's
what does this all mean
what
sega in the page
well i think it's page three your your
draft isn't um
the number there are any numbers
it's right at the bottom
of page three
okay i see it so basically mr williams
this is just saying uh to give this
commission
a public face
so that public
interest and public energy and public
pressure could be applied if
hospitals are not participating that
that the dhhs
would use their website web
site to
[Music]
host a page
basically dedicated to this commission
and then it would meet the standards of
any website that it should be searchable
um you know the like do you want to do
you want to comment on that that because
that is that is new work
for the record john williams the
director for relative affairs with the
new hampshire department of health and
services and i just on a very high level
just want to say that our is in support
of this very important initiative i
believe
rev edwards there was not only a
commentary that you had seen from the
health human services oversight
committee on friday but this is
something certainly our agency
would fulfill our obligations around the
legislation uh it's also acknowledged
that because of the effective date being
um july 1st of 2023 unless in your your
amendment i apologize if it's changed a
date
if that's the occasion then the costs
associated with this and i would agree
uh with mr ripple that we need to
provide you with a updated digital
worksheet at least as it relates to new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home
which glenn cliff home clearly uh being
a long-term care facility wouldn't fall
under this but we could build in
whatever costs associated with the bill
uh through the budget process in the
24-25 budget so the agency does support
whatever iteration that you work out on
this bill um we do also want to point
out that the bill as uh it came to this
committee
still had components to it that would
have some fiscal implications to the
department uh one would be the
enforcement of the fines as it came to
your committee in the other piece and
it's out of here and i like that very
very good for the audience um and the
other uh piece of it would be even
though it doesn't use the words
administratively attached to the
department in many fashions the
commission the way the language is
drafted we would have to provide some
level of support but again i say all of
that with we would
work collaboratively with the
legislature to build into the budget to
accommodate for that based on the
effective date of the bill
so after hearing you
go through all of that then you are fine
with the department um
maintaining a website
that was my specific part about that i
wanted to know whether you were okay
with that
and
represent edwards i i hope that the
background i did provide was helpful but
yes i did not directly answer
representative walner's question and as
we have worked collaboratively with the
legislature in the past posting on the
department website seems not to be
anything onerous at all and in fact i
think consistent with our goals of
promoting this particular initiative
great thank you
thank you mr williams uh
chair vice chair leon
have you have you heard enough of the
discussion on 459 or if you could give
us some some words on whether you think
uh what we've done here is consistent
with the direction if not the
literal
translation of the bill
yes thank you mr chairman and i did
arrive just as you were beginning the
discussion so i was able to catch most
of it
it looks like this has been a nice
attempt to sort of soften those edges
and get it more towards something that
will address the goals without
that big fine issue
anything that's in the licensing statute
we heard is something that if somebody
jeopard somebody does not follow it
jeopardizes their license
so i feel that there's already a lot of
heft behind anything that you're doing
here in this section that's actually why
in the senate they move the patient's
bill of rights out of the licensing
statute and put it in the patient's bill
of rights section so that it doesn't
have the same heft and weight that it
would in licensing
with that having it
as a may
for or having it as a shell for anybody
that is more than three urgent cares
does provide a good carve out now i am
concerned that that's going to lock in
those small facilities
as being one or two location only and
inhibit their potential growth because
if a new hampshire facility would need
one full-time employee to implement this
i can only imagine that an urgent care
would also need one full-time employee
so i remain concerned about the shell
because of those those small urgent
cares
but i do agree that this is a very
important program um i i do have
questions though as to
if the strangulations happening at
dartmouth are already in violation of
law
and if they are how adding this is going
to do anything to make them safer if
those if those people that have
strangled people at dartmouth hitchcock
are not being prosecuted maybe there's a
bigger problem that we need to address
as well
so i guess those are my takeaways i
think you guys are doing great work
um i probably might assume that was
rhetorical
if you want i was going to say to my
knowledge the prosecutor the question is
what kind of security is they happen in
the er what kind of
what kind of security is in the er to
prevent them from happening that was the
question
um
that's a really good facility choice
when i was down at boston medical center
when i broke my femur some of the people
that came in with gunshot wounds from
gang warfare were guarded there because
that was something they needed to do to
keep their patients safe
i hope we don't end up with lockdown ers
like you do down at boston medical
center but if that is part of providing
safe care that's part of that duty of
care whether it's written to this law or
not
you know the way i recall it is uh
because i used to work with um hospital
architects on re-engineering for image
management networks and so i had a
chance to work through a lot of this and
i i think there's like a jcho
architectural standard of things that
they should consider or contemplate in
the design of their new facilities and i
i am i think the security next to the er
has has been a big thing for decades
i know when i started working in
hospitals in 1970 they had the security
right next to the er so
go ahead if i may that actually brings
up another big question
when reading through this it says that
if you're already
under the join accreditation commission
you still follow that
i don't know if dartmouth follows that
but as an institution of their size and
heft i would assume that they're jayco
certified
so if they're already following a
program that allows them to opt out of
this program i'm not sure how that would
provide any more safety to
to this
i can't believe they were strangled
there but i don't know how this would
provide any more safety because those
sort of things should never happen but i
don't think this would fix it for them
if they're already following the joint
accreditation
you missed where we're going to add in
nobody can strangle anyone in the
hospital that's that that's in there
nobody can strangle on any anyone
anywhere including a hospital
especially a hospital especially a
hospital perfect all right so with that
i are there any last comments
anyone
uh we're gonna we're gonna get what what
time are we getting tomorrow 11 30
when uh well you have the full committee
at nine um
i actually have to check on tomorrow
but i will just add that i did receive
the uh senate bill 275 amendment from
ols so if you do want to do that today
you can do it today let's let me check
uh when we're meeting tomorrow i think
we're meeting at 11 30 11 30
um brief discussion are we going to be
here at 9.
okay so we're we're on the calendar for
11 30. let's let's wait on 275. if you
can distribute to everyone and if
everyone would just read what it it what
the amendment to 275 is we could
probably knock that now in about 10
minutes tomorrow
all right
i think that's a full day so uh
do i have a motion to adjourn
second second
we are in adjournment
or are we still in resource for 275
we're yeah
you